Hey. Hey, Sean, I do want to get into this. I know we got to do a cold open for the show, but I'm flying in New York today. So I got to... Why are you going? Why are you coming here? Why are you coming in here?
嘿。嘿，肖恩，我确实想聊聊这个。我知道我们得为节目做个开场白，但我今天得飞纽约。所以我得……你为什么要走？你为什么要来这儿？你为什么要来这儿？
I got to go take care of some stuff. And I just don't... I mean, I'm not trying to be vague about it. But, no, I just got to do some stuff. I got to go to New York. I got to go... I got to come evict you from your apartment. Okay?
我得去处理一些事情。我不是……我的意思是，我不是想含糊其辞。但，不，我就是得处理些事情。我得去纽约。我得去……我得去把你从公寓里赶出来。好吗？
Are you happy? Welcome to Smartless. Jason, you're still coughing. I'm still coughing. I'm still coughing. You guys both got it, right? Yeah, I'm doing a little better. But you're still, you've got it in the lungs?
你开心吗？欢迎来到《Smartless》。杰森，你还在咳嗽。我也在咳嗽。我也在咳嗽。你们俩都中招了，对吧？是啊，我好多了。但你还在……你的肺部还有症状吗？
Everybody's working for the weekend. See, I have enough energy to do that. I know I can get, Sean. I knew I could live. Everybody's working for the weekend. Hey, band, right now, J.B., who's saying that? You want a piece of my heart? Yeah, that's not.
每个人都在为周末而工作。你看，我有足够的精力做那个。我知道我能行，肖恩。我知道我能活下来。每个人都在为周末而工作。嘿，乐队，现在，J.B.，谁在说那个？你想要我的一颗心吗？是的，那不是。
He had a headband. Tiger bomb. Fucking close. White tiger. Tiger bomb. Sort of. Tiger's milk. No.
他戴着头带。虎标万金油。该死，很接近了。白虎。虎标万金油。差不多吧。老虎奶。不。
Tiger's milk? No. Wasn't it lover boy? Yes, lover boy. That's what I said. That's weird. By the way, by the way, by the way, honestly, and I don't want to get too philosophical because it's the new year and stuff like that.
老虎奶？不。难道不是Loverboy乐队吗？是的，Loverboy。我就是这么说的。真奇怪。顺便说一句，顺便说一句，顺便说一句，老实说，我不想变得太哲学，因为现在是新年之类的。
But it is, there is something to it. Everybody is working for the week. God. You know? I'll tell you what, we just went through the holidays here, listener. You sure did. And every day seemed like a Saturday.
但确实，这其中有些门道。每个人都在为周末而工作。天哪。你知道吗？我告诉你，我们刚过完节，听众朋友们。你们确实过完了。而且每一天看起来都像星期六。
And I was really excited about that. I loved it. But I feel like my brain got real labby. Yeah. Like I don't know. Now I'm like afraid to go outside. I feel like I'll have culture shock if I like run into somebody that's like a serious person. Somebody last night I was talking to,
我对此感到非常兴奋。我喜欢那样。但我觉得我的大脑变得非常迟钝。是的。就像我不知道。现在我害怕出门了。我觉得如果我遇到一个正经人，我会产生文化冲击。昨晚我和某人聊天，
J.B., you and I were texting a little bit during the last weekend of football. We're dating this when we're recording this, but we're talking about football and stuff, and I was talking to our old buddy, Eli. Is that right? Oh, I do miss Eli. I love Eli. Sweet Eli.
J.B.，上个橄榄球周末期间我们发过短信。我们录制这期节目时是在约会，但我们在聊橄榄球之类的，我当时在和我们的老朋友伊莱聊天。是这样吗？哦，我确实想念伊莱。我爱伊莱。可爱的伊莱。
And he was saying, the holidays are over. Like, tonight's the last night. Like, it was the last football game of the regular season. Like, it was the last weekend after the thing. And the year starts. And honestly, I gotta say, I'm really happy about that. I had, we were all sick over the holiday. from starting Christmas Day,
他说，假期结束了。就像，今晚是最后一晚。就像，这是常规赛的最后一场橄榄球比赛。就像，这是假期后的最后一个周末。新的一年开始了。老实说，我得说，我对此感到非常高兴。我们所有人在假期都病了，从圣诞节那天开始，
had the thing, J.B., that you've had. Sean, which you now have. I think Jason gave it to me, yeah. Yeah, that big Thanksgiving trichis that we labeled it, right? Just as we were leaning in, we said, let's call this a tricist. And then you guys got it. A turduccott. It was a turduckeet kiss.
得了那个东西，J.B.，你得过的那个。肖恩，你现在得的那个。我想是杰森传染给我的，是的。是的，那个我们称之为“感恩节火鸡病”的东西，对吧？就在我们深入讨论时，我们说，把它叫作“火鸡病”。然后你们就中招了。火鸡三明治。那是一个火鸡三明治之吻。
So I'm just, I'm like, at this point after we spent, which was nice, again, we felt very fortunate we got to just be at home with the family with all my kids and we had sort of 10 days kind of sequestered on the East Coast, but I'm looking forward to emerging from this. Yeah, a little bit from this. Yeah, I know. And here we are. We're starting right back.
所以，在经历了这一切之后，我感觉……再次强调，我们感到非常幸运，能和家人、我的孩子们待在家里，我们在东海岸被隔离了大约10天，但我期待着从这种状态中走出来。是的，稍微走出来一点。是的，我知道。我们现在就在这儿。我们又开始了。
We're at work now. 9.30, Monday of morning. We're a little out of practice, right? I know. I'm really nervous about today's episode, you guys. Nobody's done, and we haven't covered the weather or the traffic yet. I think there's a sig alert on the 210. How do you stretch out for a podcast?
我们现在在工作。周一早上9点半。我们有点生疏了，对吧？我知道。伙计们，我真的很紧张今天的节目。没人做准备，我们还没聊天气或交通呢。我想210号公路有交通警报。你做播客前怎么热身？
podcast. Jason, you're going to arrive in about 10 more minutes. I can tell. Jason's got his, he's wearing a hoodie, and he's got the hoodie up, and he's got his headphones on the outside of his hoodie. He's still trying to stay cozy like I'm making fires still. Wait, yeah, tell me, but what do you mean, Jay, when you said that? Because I think the same thing when I, I was thinking about you about, like, you were like, I love being cozy, watching movies, and not going anywhere. I'm kind of the same way. And then I know what you mean like, oh shoot, this has to end and like the world starts again. Sean, you're really on the fence between the,
播客。杰森，你大约10分钟后会到。我看得出来。杰森穿着连帽衫，把帽子戴上，耳机戴在连帽衫外面。他还在试图保持舒适，就像我还在生火一样。等等，是的，告诉我，你刚才说那个是什么意思，杰？因为我想法和你一样，我在想你的时候，你就像是，我喜欢待在舒适的地方，看电影，哪儿也不去。我也差不多。然后我知道你的意思，就像，哦糟糕，这必须结束，世界又开始了。肖恩，你真的处于……之间，
well, I got a couple things. A, there's that. Because you say you like to cozy and do nothing. But the truth is, you also like to just rifle things off a checklist. Absolutely. You never stop. That's right. I don't want to think about it.
嗯，我有几件事。A，有那个原因。因为你说你喜欢舒适，什么都不做。但事实是，你也喜欢把清单上的事情一件件划掉。绝对是。你从不停下来。没错。我不想考虑它。
Because if I don't, I know, we talk about this a million times. If I don't check it off or respond or something, then it lingers in my head. I'm like, I gotta do that. And I just don't want to think about it. I know. So there's that. What's your email inbox look like?
因为如果我不这样做，我知道，我们谈过一百万次了。如果我不把它划掉或回复什么的，它就会在我脑子里挥之不去。我就想，我得做那个。我就是不想考虑它。我知道。所以就是这样。你的电子邮件收件箱是什么样的？
Is it clean or is it closed? Always zero. If it's not zero, I panic. Yeah. Me too. Empty. Except for the only things that are in there means I need. All the emails are in there, but there's just no new messages.
是空的还是满的？永远是零。如果不是零，我就恐慌。是的。我也是。空的。除了里面仅有的那些我需要的东西。所有的邮件都在里面，但没有新消息。
Yeah, I need, if it's still in my inbox, I need to respond to it. That's right. That's how I feel. But you don't delete all the emails you got. No, but they've been read. But that's when, I'm amazed when I see people, I'm amazed when I see somebody's phone, and the messages of the emails are like 2,300. That's the side of.
是的，我需要，如果它还在我的收件箱里，我就需要回复它。没错。我就是这种感觉。但你不会删除你收到的所有邮件。不，但它们都被读过了。但这就是让我惊讶的地方，当我看到别人的手机，看到邮件数量是2300封时，我很惊讶。那是……的标志。
That's a sign of... I don't know how to sink my accounts, yes. No, no, no, no, no. You need to go and get an assessment if that's happening. Or an assistant. A deep... A deep... No, not an assistant.
那是……的标志。我不知道怎么同步我的账户，是的。不，不，不，不，不。如果发生这种情况，你需要去接受评估。或者找个助理。深……深……不，不是助理。
Or that. That sort of betrays a deeper. Like, you need a lot of assistance at this point, and we're going to send somebody over to the house. The other thing is, J.B., I want to know. Yeah. Over the holiday. How much wood did you go through?
或者那个。那暴露了更深层的问题。就像，你现在需要很多帮助，我们要派人去你家。另一件事是，J.B.，我想知道。是的。假期期间。你用了多少木头？
Kind of wood, chuck-tuck. And Sean, that question is going to go for you, but it's going to be on a different subject. Go ahead. J.B., how much wood did you get through? Consistent with Sean's answer, I think I went through two loads. Wow. Very nice.
什么木头，土拨鼠。肖恩，那个问题也问你，但主题不同。说吧。J.B.，你用了多少木头？和肖恩的回答一致，我想我用了两车。哇。非常好。
Way to lend that. What did they say? I said you show up in about 10 minutes. It only took like four. He's back. He is back, you guys. 2026, look out. All right.
真会借题发挥。他们说什么？我说你大约10分钟后到。只花了四分钟。他回来了。伙计们，他回来了。2026年，小心了。好了。
Well, speaking of brain mushyness, this is perfect. My guest today is a fellow podcaster, but that's about where the overlap ends. You can't even make your own writing sound natural. You wrote it and you make it sound like it's red. It's insane. Oh, I'll read the whole thing right in front of you. He's got a PhD in neuroscience.
好吧，说到大脑迟钝，这太完美了。我今天的嘉宾是一位同行播客，但我们的交集也就到此为止了。你甚至不能让你自己的文字听起来自然。你写了它，却让它听起来像是在读稿。这太疯狂了。哦，我会在你面前读完整段。他拥有神经科学博士学位。
He's a tenured professor at Stanford School of Medicine in neurobiology and ophthalmology and by courtesy, psychiatry and behavioral sciences. His work's been featured in Time, BBC. scientific American, basically every publication that makes me feel dumb. His podcast is one of the most downloaded in the world. It's the cold plunging, dopamine optimizing, sunstaring, science genius, Andrew Huberman. Great.
他是斯坦福医学院神经生物学和眼科学的终身教授，并兼任精神病学和行为科学教授。他的工作曾被《时代周刊》、《BBC》、《科学美国人》报道，基本上所有让我觉得自己很蠢的出版物都报道过。他的播客是世界上下载量最大的播客之一。他就是冷水浸泡、多巴胺优化、凝视太阳的科学天才，安德鲁·休伯曼。太棒了。
Finally. Good morning and happy New Year. Good morning. Happy New Year. How are you? Doing great. Yeah. How's your brain fog today? Are you flabby from the holiday?
终于来了。早上好，新年快乐。早上好。新年快乐。你好吗？非常好。是的。你今天的大脑雾怎么样？假期过得迟钝吗？
Yeah, I spent this holiday like I've spent so many holidays working. In the past, it used to be grants, and now it was doing book edits. But I'm very familiar with this what you called flabby brain thing that happens after about four days away from, I don't know if it's the grind or the work, but it's a normal thing, and you snap right back. Yeah. Yeah. Being sick doesn't help.
是的，我像往常一样在假期里工作。过去通常是申请拨款，现在是在编辑书稿。但我非常熟悉这种你所说的假期后大脑迟钝的感觉，这通常发生在离开工作大约四天之后，我不知道这是不是因为忙碌或工作，但这很正常，你会很快恢复的。是的。是的。生病也没什么帮助。
I took some notes here as I was sitting there in the backdrop. This thing that's been going around is rough. It's no joke. I'll just say there are a couple of things. that are supported by the peer-reviewed literature that can really help accelerate moving through something like what you all know with. I had it too a couple months ago.
我坐在后台时记了一些笔记。这种正在流行的病很严重。这不是开玩笑。我只想说有几件事。同行评审文献支持这些方法，可以真正帮助加速从你们所知道的那种状态中恢复。几个月前我也得过。
Three things. It turns out that the old practice of hot baths is actually quite good. You don't want to make it scalding, obviously, but you get into a just tolerably hot bath. Oh, I'm writing this down. And it turns out it mobilizes some features of the immune system in ways that can help you get over your sickness.
三件事。事实证明，古老的热水澡练习实际上相当不错。显然你不想把它弄得滚烫，但你可以泡在一个刚好能忍受的热水澡里。哦，我正在记下来。事实证明，它能以某种方式调动免疫系统的某些功能，帮助你从疾病中恢复。
Well, just because you sweat it out. Is that what it... No, dummy. Just let him finish. You're activating some of the mobilization of some of the cells and scavenge for whatever it is that you're dealing with. This is particularly useful at the beginning. Your immune system has two different phases.
嗯，只是因为你把它汗蒸出来了。是那个意思吗……不，笨蛋。让他说完。你正在激活某些细胞的动员，并清除你正在处理的任何东西。这在初期特别有用。你的免疫系统有两个不同的阶段。
There's a kind of an innate phase where it's like any foreign invader gets kind of the same inflammation response. That's good. That's the kind of like, oh, you know, I'm feeling a little like under. I'm a little extra tired. That's the time, ideally in the hour or two before bed, you take a nice hot bath or hot shower and then just get into bed.
有一种先天阶段，就像任何外来入侵者都会得到某种相同的炎症反应。那很好。那种感觉就像，哦，你知道，我感觉有点……我有点特别累。那是时候了，理想情况下是在睡前一两个小时，洗个舒服的热水澡或热水淋浴，然后直接上床睡觉。
And, you know, if you do that for a couple days in a row, you may be able to defend it off. If not, once you have it, keeping that practice up, provided you don't have a really high fever, is really useful. And, you know, I know I'm always talking about the morning sunlight. Please say smoking cigarettes.
而且，你知道，如果你连续几天这样做，你也许能抵御它。如果没有，一旦你得了，保持这种习惯，前提是你没有高烧，是非常有用的。而且，你知道，我总是谈论早晨的阳光。请说吸烟。
Just set your circadian row. No, but we can talk about nicotine if you want. A lot to say about nicotine. But getting some what we call long wavelength light, So some sunlight or I'm not here to say red light therapy, but getting some sunlight, this is very well supported by the literature because again, it's helpful for your mitochondrial function
只是设定你的昼夜节律。不，但如果你想的话，我们可以谈谈尼古丁。关于尼古丁有很多可说的。但获取一些我们称之为长波长的光，也就是一些阳光，或者我不是在这里提倡红光疗法，但获取一些阳光，这在文献中得到了很好的支持，因为再次强调，它对你的线粒体功能有帮助，
for your immune system. In Arctic countries, not so much Arctic, but in Scandinavia, in Russia, they actually put babies bundled up out in the cold in the morning to mobilize these things. Yeah, we throw them outside. Here we don't do that. Here that'll get you child protection services.
对你的免疫系统有帮助。在北极国家，不是那么北极，但在斯堪的纳维亚，在俄罗斯，他们实际上把婴儿裹得严严实实放在早晨的寒冷中来动员这些东西。是的，我们把他们扔到外面。在这里我们不那样做。在这里那样做会让你被儿童保护服务机构盯上。
No, but up in Canada. Oh, it'll be fine. We'll toss her outside for sure. And there are a couple other things we can talk about, but in Inakis. Wait a second. Now, listen, Andrew, nice to meet you, first of all. Yeah, it's so great you're here. I wanted you on for so long.
不，但在加拿大。哦，没事的。我们肯定会把她扔到外面。还有几件事我们可以谈谈，但在Inakis。等一下。现在，听着，安德鲁，首先很高兴见到你。是的，你能来真是太好了。我一直想请你来。
Okay, shut up. Can I call you Huberman? You can call me whatever you want. Okay. How about Doc? Because I refer to you as Huberman as if I know you all the time because I've seen clips of yours online for years and stuff. And so I like a lot of the stuff you talk about.
好了，闭嘴。我可以叫你休伯曼吗？你想怎么叫我就怎么叫我。好的。叫博士怎么样？因为我一直把你称为休伯曼，好像我很了解你一样，因为我多年来一直在网上看你的片段之类的。所以我很喜欢你谈论的很多东西。
First of all, you lost Jason when you said Bath because he's thinking about his own. juices. He hates marinating in juices. I don't understand the concept of it. A lot of men don't like baths. I hate it. A lot of men like baths, a lot of men don't. It's just the math is wrong. Sona would be fine. Sona would be fine.
首先，当你提到洗澡时，你失去了杰森，因为他在想他自己的汁液。他讨厌浸泡在汁液里。我不理解这个概念。很多男人不喜欢洗澡。我讨厌它。很多男人喜欢洗澡，很多男人不喜欢。这只是数学不对。桑拿会很好。桑拿会很好。
Okay. So Sona, so interestingly, interestingly enough, and by the way, not that interesting. When I was starting to get this flu, I looked it up, I consulted, I did my own research, as they say, meaning I have Google. A lot of people like to talk about research and what they mean is that they use the internet. like a bunch of fucking dummies.
好的。所以桑拿，有趣的是，有趣的是，顺便说一句，没那么有趣。当我开始得流感时，我查了一下，我咨询了，我做了我自己的研究，正如他们所说，意思是我有谷歌。很多人喜欢谈论研究，而他们的意思是他们使用互联网。像一群该死的笨蛋。
And it told me because I've been a proponent of sauna and cold plungeers always. For more than 10 years. Early days. And they said to me, the internet they said, don't expose myself if I have the flu that they were worried about because they said that your body's already working hard enough. They were saying don't do the coal plunger. Don't do the hot.
它告诉我，因为我一直都是桑拿和冷水浸泡的拥护者。超过10年了。早期。他们对我说，互联网他们说，如果我得了他们担心的流感，不要暴露自己，因为他们说你的身体已经工作得够辛苦了。他们说不要做冷水浸泡。不要做热水。
Don't do either, because they were saying, because I'd have to fight hard enough. So this was the first time when I was sick that I did not use the heat and or the cold to try to combat it. And it ended up being harsher. And now that I'm hearing you, I wish I had, because historically I've always just gone in
什么都不要做，因为他们说，因为我必须足够努力地战斗。所以这是我生病时第一次没有使用热和/或冷来尝试对抗它。结果变得更严重了。现在我听你这么说，我希望我当时做了，因为历史上我总是直接进去，
and I saw in early days when I start to feel that thing in my throat or whatever, and usually I'm able to stave it off. So you're saying... Yeah, you know that the cold, deliberate cold exposure, right? showers, cold plunges, this kind of thing. It is a stressor. Counter to what you hear out there, it does not raise cortisol, but it is a stressor. Your adrenaline spikes when you get in the cold, which is part of the reason you do it. And then when you get out, you get that long tail of dopamine and epinephrinellane adrenaline that makes you feel much better and more alert, etc.
当我开始感觉到喉咙里有那种东西或什么的，通常我能够抵御它。所以你是说……是的，你知道那种寒冷，刻意的冷暴露，对吧？淋浴，冷水浸泡，这种东西。这是一种压力源。与你听到的相反，它不会提高皮质醇，但它是一种压力源。当你进入寒冷时，你的肾上腺素会飙升，这就是你做它的部分原因。然后当你出来时，你会得到那种长尾的多巴胺和肾上腺素，让你感觉好多了，更警觉等等。
That's fine under healthy conditions. I would say if you're battling something or you feel like you're coming down with something, use heat, sauna, hot shower, hot bath, whatever it is that works for you. But I would drop the cold as you're getting into something because it's a very potent stressor. The thing about heat is if it's too hot, it can also be a stressor. I mean, when you're healthy, using the sauna as a way to get your heart rate up
在健康状况下这很好。我会说如果你正在对抗什么东西或者你觉得你快要生病了，使用热，桑拿，热水淋浴，热水澡，任何对你有用的东西。但我会放弃寒冷，因为当你进入某种状态时，它是一个非常强效的压力源。关于热的一点是，如果太热，它也可能是一个压力源。我的意思是，当你健康时，使用桑拿作为一种提高心率的方式，
and kind of push it in there a little bit is good. By the way, useful tip, if you put a towel over your head or you'll notice that Russian banyas, they wear those little hot. I have a sauna hat. Yeah, it insulates your brain from the heat so you can stay in longer.
并稍微推动一下是好的。顺便说一句，有用的提示，如果你在头上放一条毛巾，或者你会注意到俄罗斯桑拿，他们戴那些小热帽。我有一个桑拿帽。是的，它能隔绝你的大脑免受热量影响，这样你就能待得更久。
The impulse to get out is a brain thing. not unless it's very, very hot, a burn thing. And then, of course, if men want to conceive children in the next 90 days, because of the 90 days from metagenesis cycle, if you're going into the sauna, you need to put a cold packet you're growing outside your shorts, guys. If you don't want children, also don't use this as a surefire way
出来的冲动是大脑的问题，除非它非常非常热，那是烧伤的问题。然后，当然，如果男人们想在未来90天内受孕，因为从生精周期开始的90天，如果你要进桑拿房，你需要把一个冷包放在你的短裤外面，伙计们。如果你不想要孩子，也不要把它当作避免生孩子的万无一失的方法。这是，你知道，很多意外。你得把你的蛋蛋放在冰里，呃？你是说桑拿会，会减少你的精子数量？绝对会。热和精子，不是一个好的组合，这就是为什么我们要谈到解剖学，这就是为什么阴囊可以伸展和收缩靠近身体。
to avoid having children. It's, you know, many accidents. You've got to stick your nuts and ice, eh? Like, you're saying that the sauna will, will cut your sperm count? Absolutely. Heat and sperm, not a good combo, which is why we're getting to anatomy here, which is why the scrotum can extend and contract closer to the body.
这是为了保持精子发生的最佳温度。那个怎么样？是的。所以如果你在尝试受孕前的90天里经常去桑拿或洗热水澡，你会限制高活力精子的数量。话虽如此，我相信很多孩子是在桑拿和热水澡以及炎热的条件下受孕的。
It's to maintain the optimal temperature for spermatogenesis. How about that? Yeah. And so if you go in a sauna or a hot baths quite a bit in the 90 days prior to trying to conceive, you're going to limit the number of highly mobile sperm. That said, I'm sure many children have, been conceived in saunas and hot baths and in hot conditions.
但这只是平均而言，对吧？无可奉告。无可奉告。天哪，我现在应该有很多孩子了。现在，让我们回到你刚才说的，博士，关于，请详细说明尼古丁，因为我们的联合主持人在这里咀嚼他的尼古丁口香糖。当然。那是……不是……
But this is on average, right? No comment. No comment. God, I would have had tons of kids by now. Now, let's get back to what you were saying, Dr. about, please expand on nicotine as one of our co-hosts here, choose his Nicorette gum. Sure. Is that... It's not...
你在找免费赠品吗？我做Zinn口香糖组合。好的，关于这个我有很多话要说。在那之前，非常快地……首先我想做一个完整的免责声明，我与我即将描述的内容没有任何经济关系。有一项美丽的研究发表了，它在PubMed上，如果你们想要，我可以发给你们链接，我是从洛杉矶的一位急诊医生那里学到的，他需要在冬季保持健康，N-乙酰半胱氨酸，也叫NAC，是一种谷胱甘肽前体。
Are you looking for freebies? I do a Zinn gum combo. Okay, I have a lot to say about this. Before I do that, just very quickly... there's there first of all i want to put a full disclaimer i have no financial relationship to what i'm about to describe in any way there's a beautiful study published and it's on pub med i can send you guys the link if you want and i learned about this from an er doc out here in los angeles who need to keep himself healthy during the winter season endacetyl cysteine also called knack is a glutathione precursor
有一项美丽的研究表明，当人们报名参加一项研究时，他们被故意暴露在患有流感的人群中。他们要么每天两到三次服用NAC，剂量约为每天600到900毫克，要么不服用。但抱歉，请描述一下NAC是什么，因为你说了那个长词。我不知道那是什么。N-乙酰半胱氨酸，它是谷胱甘肽的前体，用于许多不同的细胞过程。通常，我认为你不需要这个，对吧？你不需要提高谷胱甘肽。
there's a beautiful study showing that when they people signed up for a study where they would where they were deliberately exposed to people who had flu. And they either got NAC two or three times a day at about 600 to 900 milligrams per day or not. But sorry, just describe what NAC is because you said that long word. I don't know what that is. And acetyl cysteine, it's a precursor to something called glutathione, which is used in a bunch of different cellular processes. Normally, I think you don't need this, right? You don't need elevate glutathione.
我知道现在打谷胱甘肽点滴之类的很流行。我对所有这些都有一个更传统的看法。但如果你觉得你快要生病了，或者你将要接触到某些东西。或者杰森，你提到你要去纽约。你有工作要做。你需要你更快地恢复。关于通过每天两到三次服用600到900毫克N-乙酰半胱氨酸来避免生病的数据，当你生病或试图避免生病时，是相当稳健的。事实上，在所有暴露于同一种病毒（在这种情况下是流感病毒）的人数中，没有感染病毒的人数有巨大差异。
I know it's all the rage now to get glutathione drips and that sort of thing. I have a more conventional opinion about all that. But if you feel like you're coming down with something or you're going to be exposed to things. Or Jason, you mentioned that you're heading off to New York. You've got work to do. You need you to recover more quickly. The data on avoiding getting sick by taking 600 to 900 milligrams of an acetyl cysteine two or three times a day, when you're sick getting sick or trying to avoid getting sick is quite robust. In fact, there's a huge difference in the number of people all exposed to the same virus that flu virus in this case that did not contract the virus.
有些人还是感染了。比例在20%多，但如果他们不服用，对照组接近80%。这相当令人印象深刻。显然要咨询你的医生，这种事情。但这是唯一的一件事，
Some still did. It's in the high 20s, but had they not taken it, the control group was somewhere close to 80%. It's pretty impressive. And obviously check with your doctor, this kind of thing. But that's the one thing,
你知道，我们听说过锌、紫锥菊，所有这些东西。这是同行评审研究实际上显示可以帮助抵御流感的唯一东西。长期服用有什么坏处吗？有些人每天会服用一点。它有一点所谓的粘液溶解作用，
you know, we hear about zinc, echinacea, all this stuff. It's the one thing that the peer-reviewed research actually shows can help stave off fluid. Is there any downside for taking it constantly? Some people will take a little bit each day. It is a little bit of what's called a mucalytic,
所以它会让你的鼻子多流一点水。它实际上被用于治疗高剂量的囊性纤维化，也就是肺部液体积聚。所以它是一种众所周知的粘液溶解剂。所以它也会帮助你排出更多。但真的没有坏处。他想排出。
so it will make your nose run just a little bit more. It's actually used to treat cystic fibrosis at very high doses, which is a build-up of fluid in the lungs. So it's a well-known eucalytic. So it's going to help you drain out more as well. But no, there's really no downside. He wants to drain out.
他，他只听到了排出，他太兴奋了。如果我能减掉水分，我就很高兴。我有一种感觉，这与我们之前的讨论有关。等一下，等一下。一个小时的时间和尿液是不够的，肖恩。我们有这么多。你会放这么多盒子。我做梦。
He, all he heard was drain out, and he's so excited. If I'm losing water weight, I'm happy. I have a feeling that's related to our previous discussion. Wait a second, wait a second. We're not going to, an hour is not going to be enough time with urine, Sean. We have so many. You will put so many boxes. I dream.
但我很想知道我们的朋友是否，我很想知道我们的朋友是否安全，为Zen加油。因为已经有很多，我想通过说，关于尼古丁对你有好处已经有很多讨论了。人们现在说它很棒，所有这些东西。所以我很想听听你对尼古丁和各种输送系统的看法。太棒了。
But I want to know if our friend is, I want to know if our friend is safe, cheering on the Zen. Because there's been so much, and I want to set it up by saying, there's been so much about nicotine is good for you. People are now saying it's great, all this sort of stuff. And so I want to hear once and fro what your take is on nicotine and the various delivery systems. Great.
尼古丁是一种非常有趣的兴奋剂。它是一种兴奋剂。当然。但它可能是唯一一种同时也能让你放松的兴奋剂。谢谢安德鲁来参加播客。所以这是一个非常独特的属性，对吧？它让你保持警觉但专注，
Nicotine is a very interesting stimulant. It is a stimulant. Sure. But it's perhaps the only stimulant. that also relaxes you at the same time. Thank you, Andrew, for coming on the podcast. So that's a very unique property, right? It gives you that alert but focused,
让你进入那种对人类如此诱人的状态，以至于，我将避免深入探讨尼古丁的历史，但我们只说几百年来，特别是过去一百年，人类已经找到了将尼古丁送入大脑的方法。我们知道吸烟、电子烟、嚼烟和鼻烟，都会导致癌症，我确实把电子烟放进去了。电子烟可能比吸烟更安全，
kind of puts you in the groove that is so alluring to humans, so much so, and I'm going to avoid going into a history about nicotine, but let's just say for hundreds of years, but in particular in the last hundred years, humans have figured out ways to get nicotine into their brain. And we know that smoking, vaping, dipping, and snuffing, all cause cancer, and I did put vaping in there. Vaping is perhaps safer than smoking,
但仍然会导致肺部损伤，污染物等等。电子烟很糟糕。我只想说。关于金属燃烧和所有这些东西的科学还没有定论。而且我会说，根据轶事，当我尝试使用其中一种电子烟产品时，我不会说哪一种，它增加了我的血压，
but still causes lung damage, the contaminants, et cetera. Vaping is bad. I'm just going to say. The science isn't back yet on the burning of the metal and all that kind of stuff. And I will say anecdotally, when I tried to use one of the vaping products, I'm not going to say which one, it increased my blood pressure,
它增加了我的焦虑十倍，我停止使用了。是的，我会采取强硬立场。显然，吸烟，我们现在知道了。仍然很酷。没有人真的嚼烟或吸鼻烟，或者人们嚼烟，但他们不。我祖父过去常吸鼻烟。他过去常放一点在他的……
it increased my anxiety tenfold, and I went back off it. Yeah, I'll take a hard stance. Obviously, smoking, we now know. Still cool. No one dips or snuffs, really, or people dip, but they don't. My grandfather used to snuff. He used to put a little bit on his...
是的，我也是。是的，他过去常粉末。字面意思就是把烟草放进鼻孔。我甚至无法想象。好的。好吧，那么情况是这样的。我们从吸烟、嚼烟、电子烟和鼻烟发展而来。然后我们现在转向了所谓的电子烟，电子烟。
Yeah, mine too. Yeah, he used to powder. Literally putting tobacco up the nostrils. I can't even imagine. Okay. Well, okay, so here's the deal. We went from smoking, dipping, vaping, and snuffing. Then we moved to what they used to call electronic cigarettes, vaping.
然后现在口服尼古丁是主要的输送方式。尼古丁本身不是致癌物。这非常重要。它不会致癌，对吧？它是一种让你放松的兴奋剂，正如我提到的。它确实会升高血压并增加血管收缩。血管收缩只是小毛细血管和血管的夹紧，特别是在外周，你知道，在手指和其他四肢，以及在大脑中。而且，你知道，中风和其他类似的事情是切断大脑小区域的血液供应。所以如果你的血压已经很高，这不是一个好主意。
And then now oral nicotine is the main mode of delivery. Nicotine itself is not carcinoma. This is very important. It doesn't cause cancer, right? It's a stimulant that relaxes you, as I mentioned. It does raise blood pressure and it increases vasoconstriction. Vesa constriction is just a clamping off of the little capillaries and vessels, in particular in the periphery, you know, in the fingers, in other extremities, and in the brain. And, you know, strokes and other things like that are cutting off of blood supply to small regions of the brain. So if your blood pressure is already high, not a good idea.
如果你的血压自然很低，并且你在做其他事情，例如，桑拿，每天一次或每周至少几次血管舒张，或者如果你在旅行时洗热水澡或热水淋浴，付出一些努力，特别是在睡前确保你的毛细血管扩张，不要在一天中太晚服用尼古丁。有一个空间我可以这么说，我现在可以安全地说出我即将说的话，那就是有证据，
If your blood pressure is naturally low and you're doing other things, for instance, sauna, to vasodilate once a day or several times a week at minimum, or a hot bath if you're traveling or a hot shower, taking some effort, especially before bed to make sure that your capillaries are dilated, not taking nicotine too late in the day. There is a space where I can say, I can now safely say what I'm about to say, which is there is evidence
让我倒着做。帕金森病和阿尔茨海默病患者，如果他们服用尼古丁，似乎并没有好转。然而，在动物和人类身上有相当不错的证据表明，尼古丁，不是通过电子烟、嚼烟、吸烟或鼻烟输送的，对吧？可以预防帕金森病和阿尔茨海默病，因为它似乎保护神经元免受退化，这是帕金森病和阿尔茨海默病的标志性特征。话虽如此，我，你知道，我会感到非常舒服地说出我刚才说的话，但有些人会说，等一下，我不希望人们开始服用尼古丁来避免患上帕金森病和阿尔茨海默病。血压效应，对某些人的轻微焦虑效应是显著的。这就是重点。然后我会稍微，
let me do this backwards. People with Parkinson's and Alzheimer's, if they take nicotine, don't seem to get better. However, there is decent evidence in animals and humans that nicotine, not delivered by vaping, dipping, dipping, smoking, or snuggling, right? Can be protective against Parkinson's and Alzheimer's because it offset seems to protect neurons against degeneration, which is the hallmark feature of Parkinson's. and Alzheimer's. That said, I'm going to, you know, I'm going to feel very comfortable saying what I just said on the, but some people are going to say, wait a second, I don't want people starting to take nicotine to avoid getting Parkinson's and Alzheimer's. The blood pressure effect, the mild anxiety effect for certain people is significant. And here's the biggie. And then I'll just kind of
退后一步，听听你们对这个有什么看法。重点是它非常，任何形式的尼古丁都是高度、高度容易养成习惯的。什么？我们称它为什么？称它为成瘾。成瘾是，你知道，尽管对自己或他人造成伤害仍继续使用。我称成瘾为给你带来快乐的事物的逐渐狭窄。根据这两个定义，很难称尼古丁为成瘾。然而，我知道许多人从每天一包Zinn开始，一个口香糖，一个4毫克的口香糖，很快就是两个，很快就是四个，很快就是每三四天一罐。所以如果它不是成瘾，它就是高度容易养成习惯的。所以这就是，你知道，
peel back and hear what you guys have to say about this. The biggie is that it is highly, nicotine delivered in any form is highly, highly habit forming. What? Do we call it? call it addicting. Addicting is, you know, continued use despite harm to sell for others. I call addiction a progressive narrowing of the things that bring you pleasure. By those two definitions, it's hard to call nicotine addicting. And yet, I know many people that start with one pack of Zinn a day, one gum, one four milligram gum, pretty soon it's two, pretty soon it's four, pretty soon it's a canister every three, four days. So if it's not addicting, it's highly habit forming. So that's, you know,
我偶尔会吃一片尼古丁口香糖。是的。是的，当然。但我不会经常这样做。我不会每几周做一次以上，因为我喜欢那种强效的效果。问题是……你是说为了度过这一天或什么的？不，如果我正在进行特别长的写作会议或特别长的播客。
I'll occasionally take a piece of Nicorette. Yeah. Yeah, sure. But I don't do it very often. I won't do it more than once every couple of weeks because I love the potent effect. The problem is... Just to get through the day or something, you mean? No, if I'm doing a particularly long session of writing or a particularly long podcast.
但这就是问题所在。如果你定期服用任何种类的兴奋剂，咖啡因、尼古丁，任何种类的兴奋剂，很快你就需要它才能达到基线。没错。我的意思是，我们大多数人，世界上90%的成年人口每天都喝咖啡因，只是为了感觉他们正常的警觉水平。而且关于咖啡因的研究之所以如此之少，是因为没有人愿意经历那个过程。你必须经历两周的咖啡因戒断才能……
But here's the thing. If you take a stimulant of any kind, caffeine, nicotine, any stimulant of any kind regularly, pretty soon you need it just to get to baseline. Right. I mean, most of us drink 90% of the adult population of the world drinks caffeine every single day, just to feel at their normal levels of alertness. And the reason there's so few studies on caffeine that are really solid is because no one wants to go through the wood. You'd have to go into caffeine withdrawal for two weeks to be able to stuff.
这就是我不喝的原因。这就是我不喝咖啡因的原因。你似乎有很多精力。我不认为你需要咖啡因。而我需要咖啡因。你看起来非常警觉，就像你很白，就像你有一种警觉感。好吧，首先，我只想说，再次强调，这不像你开始那样。你早些时候说，
That's why I don't drink. That's why I don't drink caffeine. You seem to have a lot of energy. I don't think you need caffeine. Whereas I need caffeine. Like you seem very alert like you're white, like you have an alertness to you. Well, first of all, I just want to say, again, it's not like you start. You were like early on, you're like,
我不打算喝咖啡，因为我不想让我的基线必须是。不，不，不是那个。不，那不是原因。但我不想在高中时喝咖啡，当人们在喝的时候。因为我看到了人们在他们像，别打扰我。我还没喝咖啡时经历的事情。就像，我不想成为那种我没喝咖啡就不能和你说话的人。
I'm not going to drink coffee because I don't want to be my baseline to have to be. No, no, not that. No, that's not why. But I didn't want to drink coffee in high school and stuff when people were drinking. Because I saw what people went through when they're like, don't bother me. I haven't in my coffee. Like, I don't want to be that person that I can't talk to you until I've had caffeine.
你知道，或者我很生气，直到我没醒过来，直到我喝了咖啡。所以我意识到了这一点。所以我从来不想成为那样的人。所以我从来不喝咖啡。我喝过苏打水，但我现在不怎么喝苏打水了。所以，是的，就是这样。我的意思是，这就是我避免大麻的原因。我没有任何东西。
You know, or I'm angry until I'm not woken up until I have caffeine. So I recognized that. And I never wanted to be that person. So then I never drank coffee. I've had soda, but I don't really drink soda anymore. And so, yeah, that's it. I mean, that's the reason I avoided cannabis. I don't have anything.
你知道，我认为大麻，对某些人来说，它可以激活精神病，高THC。对某些人来说，他们似乎能够服用它而不会有太多麻烦。我成长过程中认识的人，成长过程中，抱歉，他们使用了很多大麻。是的。当他们无法获得大麻时，他们很难相处。哦，真的吗？相处，他们有这种，他们很易怒，是的。我们马上回来。
You know, I think cannabis has, for some people, it can activate psychosis, high THC. For some people, they seem to be able to take it and not really have too much trouble with it. The people I knew growing up, growing up, excuse me, who used a lot of cannabis. Yeah. When they didn't have access to their cannabis, they were pretty difficult to be with. Oh, really? to be with, they had this kind of, they were irritable, yeah. And we will be right back.
现在回到节目。我一直说没有比没抽大麻的瘾君子更暴躁的人了。他们总是最暴躁的人。而且有一个真正的，你可以画一条相当坚定的线。而且有，我们在说，J.B.，那些喜欢最终使用的人。J.B.刚才去小便了，我想。大麻。当他们不是，当他们不是在使用它时，可能容易变得暴躁。
And now back to the show. I've always said that there's nobody grumpier than a stoner who's not stoned. They're always the grumpiest people. And there's a real, you can really draw a pretty firm line there. And there's, we're saying, J.B., that people who like to eventually use. J.B. just took a pee break, I think. Canvas. And when they're not, when they're not using it, can be prone to being grumbly.
你觉得它容易吗，伙计？他只是想抓一些尼古丁和大麻。你是说当使用大麻的人，当他们不使用它时，他们会变得暴躁？是的。当他们无法获得它时。就像，因为我刚才说，杰，我说我不喝咖啡，因为我不想成为一个暴躁的人，
How do you think it easy, man? He just wanted to grab some nicotine and some cannabis. You're saying when people who use cannabis, they get grumpy when they're not using it? Yeah. When they don't have access to it. Like, because I was saying, Jay, I was saying I don't drink caffeine because I don't want to be like a grumpy person
直到我达到我的基线，你知道？我可能是一个很难衡量的人，因为我认为我的默认空转是，我不会说暴躁，但是是，你知道，我是那个坐在房间后面，不怎么说话，但我偶尔会扔一颗炸弹的人。没错，然后离开。
until I reach my base, you know? I might be a tough person to gauge on that because I think my set sort of default idle is, I wouldn't say grumpy, but is, you know, I'm the guy who sits at the back of the room and doesn't do a lot of talking, but I'll throw a bomb every once in a while. That's right, and then leaves.
你知道，但这让我，我不知道，我得努力改善我的个人。你不，你不符合我所想的那种人。我是在想慢性大麻吸食者。是的，慢性大麻吸食者。你知道，是的，不，
You know, but does that make me, I don't know, I got to work on my personal. You don't, you don't fit the bill of what I was thinking of. I was thinking about chronic weed smokers. Yeah, chronic weed smokers. You know, yeah, no,
不，那不是。大麻肯定会留下来。现实改变我的程度真是令人惊讶，是人们
no, that's not. Cannabis is definitely here to stay. It's kind of amazing how much the reality is changing me, is people
到处都在卖。有一些真正的问题。我认为被忽视的大问题是每个人都在谈论，哦，你知道，
sold everywhere. There are some real issues. I think the big one that's very overlooked is that everyone talks about, oh, you know,
现在的大麻比以前强多了。这是真的。THC水平高得多。但情况是这样的。我的节目上有一位研究人员，他专门研究大麻。
the weed is so much stronger now than it used to be. It's true. THC levels are much higher. But here's the thing. I had a researcher on my show who specializes in cannabis research.
他说，当人们服用可食用大麻时，那是他们倾向于经历，引用，不是过量，像致命过量，但他们服用，很难衡量那种高潮的平面，
And he said, when people take edibles, that's when they tend to go through the, quote, not overdose, like a lethal overdose, but they take, it's very hard to gauge the kind of plane of high
当人们不定期服用可食用大麻时。这就是让人们因精神病发作而进入急诊室的原因。是的，我也是。而且容易患精神病的人绝对需要避免高THC。你看到的大部分疯狂都是那样。当你吃它时，很难知道多少是太多。是的，伙计。
when people take edibles if they don't take them regularly. That's what lands people in the ER with the psychotic episode. Yeah, me too. And people who are prone to psychosis definitely need to avoid high THC. A lot of the madness you see out there is that. When you're eating it, it's hard to know how much is too much. Yeah, dude.
因为就像我可能饿了，饼干看起来不错。这就是问题，伙计。大布朗尼。是的，我曾经THC过量过几次，不是过量，但我服用太多了。THC几次，就像，我曾经躺在床上。我服用太多了，我像在摇晃，我像，
Because like I might be hungry and the cookies look good. That's the problem, dude. A big brownies. Yeah, I've OD'd on THC a couple, not ODED, but I've taken too much. THC a couple of times, and it was just like, I was lying on the bed one time. I took so much, and I was like rocking, and I'm like,
斯科蒂，斯科蒂。他说，没关系，会没事的。我说，天哪，已经三四个小时了。他说，字面意思才两分钟。我当时吓坏了。我整晚睁着眼睛睡觉。太可怕了。顺便说一句，那不是睡觉。
Scotty, Scotty. And he's like, it's okay, it's going to be okay. And I go, God, it's been like three or four hours. He goes, it's literally been two minutes. I was like freaking out. I slept in my eyes open the whole night. It was awful. It was not sleep, by the way.
我不是在睡觉。是的，好吧，任何以任何量服用大麻来睡觉的人，他们根本没有REM睡眠，没有快速眼动。哦，那很有趣。所以每个停止使用大麻的人都会得到一个——他们谈论他们的梦是多么不可思议，多么生动。你得到了REM反弹。REM是你巩固记忆的时候。
I was not sleep. Yeah, well, people who take cannabis to sleep of any kind, at any amount, they're getting no REM sleep, no rapid eye movements. Oh, that's interesting. So everyone that comes off cannabis gets a – they talk about how incredible their dreams are, how vivid their dreams are. You get a REM rebound. REM is when you consolidate memories.
REM是你学习最多的时候——你巩固你所学的。REM是必不可少的。大麻之外的一个小提示。对于任何想要增加他们获得的REM睡眠量的人，有一个绝妙的技巧，那就是你必须调整恒温器，如果你没有办法调整床的温度。但无论如何，在睡眠的最后几个小时增加睡眠环境的温度。所以你想要房间冷来入睡并保持深度睡眠。但接近早晨时，即使你必须在接近早晨时加热房间，你的REM睡眠也会显著增加。
Rem is when you learn the most – you consolidate what you learned. REM is essential. Just a little tip outside of cannabis. For anyone that wants to increase the amount of REM sleep they get, there's a wonderful trick, which is you'll have to adjust the thermostat if you don't have a way to adjust the temperature of your bed. But either way, increase the temperature in your sleeping environment in the last hours of sleep. So you want the room cold to fall asleep and stay deeply asleep. But toward morning, even if you have to heat up the room as you get toward morning, and your REM sleep will increase fairly significant.
我不会做。我不会做。你不会做。你会说你的REM睡眠真的很好吗？我的意思是，还可以。所以也许你应该做。不，但我的意思是，什么让我醒来的是太热的时候。博士，你是说如果我经常做梦，而且我有点记得我的梦，那意味着我得到了REM吗？
I won't do it. I won't do it. You won't do it. And would you say that your REM sleep is really good? I mean, it's okay. So maybe you should do it. No, but I mean, like, what wakes me out is when it's too hot. Are you saying, Doctor, that if I'm dreaming a lot and I'm kind of remembering a bit of my dreams, does that mean I'm getting REM?
是的。特别是如果梦是生动的梦。我们倾向于在夜间结束时获得更多的REM，在夜间开始时获得更多的深度睡眠。获得这个简短描述的方式是，在夜间开始时，你进入一种深度、慢波睡眠，更多的是关于身体修复。
Yes. especially if the dreams are vivid dreams. We tend to get more REM toward the end of the night and more deep sleep at the beginning of the night. The way to get the brief description of this is that at the beginning of the night, you go into a deep, slow wave sleep that's more about bodily repair.
是的，尤其是当梦境非常生动的时候。我们往往在深夜时分进入更多的快速眼动睡眠（REM），而在入睡初期则有更多的深度睡眠。简单来说，在入睡初期，你会进入一种以身体修复为主的深度慢波睡眠。
The dreams are kind of unusual. They don't really have a lot of emotional content. The way to maximize the amount of deep sleep, in addition to not drinking caffeine too close to bed, et cetera, all that, is to try and get to bed at more or less the regular time plus or minus 45 minutes. We're all human, right? Because you're going to capture that deep sleep, and then the wave passes.
梦境有些不同寻常。它们并没有太多的情感内容。除了睡前不要摄入咖啡因等常规做法外，想要最大化深度睡眠的方法，就是尽量在固定的时间上床睡觉，误差控制在45分钟以内。我们都是凡人，对吧？因为你一旦抓住了那段深度睡眠，波峰就会过去。
The way to maximize your REM sleep is to basically make sure you sleep long enough. Okay, so some people need six, some people need eight hours, whatever it is for you to feel refreshed. Yeah. But that last part of the night, if you can increase the temperature now, Sean, it sounds like you have a high core body temperature. That's great. That reflects a high metabolism. Oh, he's hot. He's all wonderful things.
想要最大化快速眼动（REM）睡眠，基本上就是要确保睡眠时间足够长。有些人需要六小时，有些人需要八小时，无论多少，只要让你感到精神焕发就行。是的。但在深夜的最后阶段，肖恩，听起来你的核心体温很高。这很好，反映了高代谢水平。哦，他很热。他浑身都是优点。
So you might just need to keep the room a little bit cooler than most. This is all relative. Yeah, yeah, God. Listen, I just say, you're just making me think, so last night this dream, this is not a joke. I was just thinking about it just came to me. I had a sick dream last night. I was in the back of a truck.
所以你可能只需要保持房间比大多数人更凉快一点。这都是相对的。是啊，天哪。听着，你让我想到一件事，昨晚那个梦，这不是开玩笑。我刚才还在想，它突然就浮现在脑海里。我昨晚做了一个疯狂的梦。我在一辆卡车的后斗里。
This is totally true with a bunch of dudes. And we're all wearing, I'm not making this up. We're all wearing gilly suits, right? Like those, like a onesies? You know, like snipers wear when they go, when they're like, you know, trying to camouflage themselves. And the rest of our crew went off. And then this one guy goes, you and me.
这是千真万确的，和一群哥们在一起。我们都穿着，我没编故事。我们都穿着吉利服，对吧？就像那种连体衣？你知道的，就像狙击手在伪装自己时穿的那种。我们的小队其他人离开了。然后有一个家伙说，你和我。
And we jumped off and we went in, and then we put up a bunch of branches so nobody knew which way we went. We went off from our regular crew. And we went off on this path, and we saw this, I'm not kidding, I'm just, and we saw this hill, and we saw this shadow of it. And he's like, those are the Russians.
我们跳了下去，走了进去，然后我们竖起了一堆树枝，这样就没人知道我们往哪个方向走了。我们脱离了常规小队。我们走上这条小路，然后我们看到了这个，我没开玩笑，我只是，我们看到了这座山，看到了它的影子。他说，那是俄国人。
And they were up on this hill. And we were going to go and try to outflank these, this sort of like spetsnots group over on this other hill. It was sick. I'm just, it was. So vivid. End of story? Shit, hang on, let him speak.
他们就在那座山上。我们打算去尝试包抄那座山上的那群特种部队。这太疯狂了。我只是，确实如此。太生动了。故事讲完了吗？该死，等等，让他说完。
Well, there's actually what we say in science, a mechanistic weave here that's, so get this. One of the things that happens during REM sleep is your acetycholine levels are high. Nicotine, believe it or not, is called nicotine because it binds to the nicotinic acetycholine receptors.
嗯，实际上科学上有一个机制性的解释，听好了。REM睡眠期间发生的事情之一是你的乙酰胆碱水平很高。信不信由你，尼古丁之所以叫尼古丁，是因为它与烟碱型乙酰胆碱受体结合。
People who take nicotine, and I'm not suggesting people go out and start taking nicotine. And I have no financial relationship to any company that makes nicotine whatsoever. Yeah. that when you boost your acetylcholine levels by taking nicotine, activation of that system with nicotine, it actually will increase.
服用尼古丁的人——我并不是建议大家去开始服用尼古丁。而且我和任何生产尼古丁的公司没有任何财务关系。是的。当你通过服用尼古丁来提高乙酰胆碱水平时，用尼古丁激活该系统，实际上会增加。
You turn into a sniper? No, you'll, well, in your case, yes, but you will increase the amount of REM that you get a little bit that night when you sleep. How about that? But Will, there's one thing I really have to give you. Yeah. Because, and actually for all the men out there and on this podcast, but it will offset some of the vaso constriction and blood pressure increase of your nicotine. But I had a guy in my podcast who was a colleague of mine at Stanford,
你变成狙击手了？不，你会，嗯，在你的情况下，是的，但你那天晚上睡觉时获得的REM睡眠量会增加一点。怎么样？但是威尔，有一件事我真的必须告诉你。是的。因为，实际上对于所有听这个播客的男士们，它会抵消一些尼古丁引起的血管收缩和血压升高。但我播客里有一位嘉宾，是我在斯坦福的同事，
Mike Eisenberg. He's our head of male sexual health and hormone clinic at Stanford. He's an MD PhD, his, the top-notch doctor in urology and this area, okay? He's a serious scientist and clinician. Every man, his words, every male, 40 years or older, should be taking low dose, meaning 2.5 to 5 milligrams of tadalophil each evening to lower their blood pressure, dilate their capillaries, at higher dose. is this is known as Cialis, right, used for erectile dysfunction. However, this drug to Dalafil was initially developed
迈克·艾森伯格。他是斯坦福男性性健康和激素诊所的负责人。他拥有医学博士和哲学博士学位，是泌尿外科和该领域的顶尖医生，好吗？他是一位严肃的科学家和临床医生。每一位40岁或以上的男性，用他的话说，都应该每天服用小剂量，即2.5到5毫克的他达拉非，以降低血压，扩张毛细血管，高剂量时。这就是所谓的西力士，对吧，用于治疗勃起功能障碍。然而，他达拉非这种药最初是开发出来的，
to treat blood pressure and for, excuse me, to dilate the small capillaries of the brain and body in order to encourage prostate health and then to encourage brain health. And there's a lot of evidence as to why this is a good thing. It's very inexpensive. It costs pennies now because it's generic for people out there. You do need a prescription.
用于治疗血压，抱歉，用于扩张大脑和身体的小毛细血管，以促进前列腺健康，进而促进大脑健康。有很多证据表明这是一件好事。它非常便宜。现在因为是仿制药，所以只要几分钱。你需要处方。
But my colleague, Mike Eisenberg, He didn't tell me to say this, but when we're talking about vaso-constricters, high blood pressure, stress, stroke, some of the leading causes of death. Every male in particular because of the prostate, women should talk to their doctors whether or not this is applicable to women.
但我的同事迈克·艾森伯格，他没让我这么说，但当我们谈论血管收缩剂、高血压、中风这些主要的死亡原因时。每一位男性，特别是考虑到前列腺问题，女性应该咨询医生这是否适用于她们。
But it will help offset some of that blood pressure and vasic restriction increase. That's amazing. Now, listen, every single day, I know you talk about supplements too. I wanted to bring this up to you because this is what I take, and it has the word nicotine in it.
但这将有助于抵消部分血压升高和血管收缩。太神奇了。现在，听着，每一天，我知道你也谈论补充剂。我想向你提起这个，因为这是我服用的，它里面有尼古丁这个词。
I take metformin and then I take nicotinamide, is that I'm saying? varitrol. Okay, so you're taking nicotinamide. I take it every day for like three years. Yeah, which is in the NAD pathway. Okay, so let's break these into metforminous to lower blood sugar. How long does you have to live? Just say it.
我服用二甲双胍，然后我服用烟酰胺，我是这么说的吗？白藜芦醇。好吧，所以你服用的是烟酰胺。我每天都吃，吃了大概三年了。是的，它在NAD通路中。好吧，让我们把这些拆解开，二甲双胍是为了降低血糖。你还得活多久？直说吧。
I mean, you guys look great. I can do like an age-guess thing, but everyone here looks like they're in their late 30s, early 40s. That's right. Oh, it's great. Likewise. Yeah, thanks. Yeah, I just turned 50. I feel really good. We're all mid-50s. We're all over 55. Wow.
我的意思是，你们看起来状态很好。我可以猜一下年龄，但这里每个人看起来都像30多岁快40岁的样子。没错。哦，太棒了。我也是。是的，谢谢。我刚满50岁。我感觉非常好。我们都是50多岁。我们都超过55岁了。哇。
But can play, I don't know, what kind of We can play from these mid-30s, late 30s. I don't know if it's a Romicon. Can even go boyish, like, you know what I mean? By the way, I loved your McCulley Culkin episode. I listened to that. I was like, this guy is so grounded. I can't even imagine being famous from that young of an age, you know.
但可以演，我不知道，什么样的，我们可以演30多岁，快40岁的角色。我不知道这算不算浪漫喜剧。甚至可以演得像个男孩，你知道我的意思吗？顺便说一句，我喜欢你那期麦考利·卡尔金的节目。我听了。我觉得这家伙太稳重了。我无法想象那么小就出名是什么感觉，你知道。
And I mean, and he's like, he's hyper-famous. And he just seems so, so grounded. I'm sure he's gone through the wickets to get there. But I was very impressed at the person. He's talking about and how groundies about everything from Legos to parenting to acting. Yeah. It was awesome. It was great.
我的意思是，他超级出名。但他看起来非常、非常稳重。我相信他经历了很多磨难才走到今天。但我对这个人印象非常深刻，他谈论的一切，从乐高到育儿再到表演，都非常脚踏实地。是的，太棒了。太棒了。
Yeah. Yeah, great. That came up because you were talking about child actors or something. I think I still frame him in Home Alone. Yeah. So supplements. To be very clear, I know I often get kind of put into that supplement cold plunge category. Look, get great sleep, sunlight.
是的，是的，太棒了。那是因为你谈到了童星什么的。我想我还是把他定格在《小鬼当家》里。是的。所以关于补充剂。要非常清楚，我知道我经常被归入那种补充剂、冷水浴的类别。听着，保证充足的睡眠，晒太阳。
I'm all about sleep, sunlight. If you drink alcohol, limit it, offset it with good behaviors, cardio resistance training. I mean, I've been doing that stuff. since I was in my teens, and I'm really committed to the behaviors come first. There is a place for some people for supplements. Metformin lowers blood glucose, blood sugar.
我非常推崇睡眠和阳光。如果你喝酒，要限制，并用良好的行为来抵消它，比如有氧运动和阻力训练。我的意思是，我从十几岁起就开始做这些事情了，我真的坚信行为优先。对于某些人来说，补充剂是有用武之地的。二甲双胍可以降低血糖。
So you can have more cheesecake, yeah. I mean, it seems to work for some people, especially you tend to run high blood sugar levels. Very high. Some people will know the kind of a poor man's version of this is actually a tree bark extract called burbering, which accomplishes the same thing. I'm writing it down.
所以你可以多吃点芝士蛋糕，是的。我的意思是，它对某些人似乎有效，特别是如果你血糖偏高的话。非常高。有些人会知道，这种药的“穷人版”实际上是一种叫做黄连素的树皮提取物，它能达到同样的效果。我正在记下来。
I mentioned that. Because, but then you would want to stop taking metformin and you'd obviously want to talk to your doctor. The other thing you're taking, nicotinamide, nicotinamide rabicide is in the NAD pathway. Okay, NAD got a lot of attention a few years back as a potential longevity thing. We all make NAD and levels of it drop off with age. There is no direct evidence yet in humans that increasing NAD either by taking what's called NR, which is what you're taking, or NMN, can extend lifespan. However, it does seem to increase energy, and NR in particular, what you're taking, seems to, there's some good human studies that it can reduce inflammation in the body.
我提到了这一点。因为，但之后你会想停止服用二甲双胍，而且你显然应该咨询你的医生。你服用的另一件事，烟酰胺，烟酰胺核糖苷在NAD通路中。好吧，NAD几年前作为一种潜在的长寿物质受到了很多关注。我们体内都会产生NAD，其水平会随年龄增长而下降。目前还没有直接证据表明，通过服用所谓的NR（你正在服用的）或NMN来增加NAD可以延长人类寿命。然而，它似乎确实能增加能量，尤其是NR，你正在服用的那种，似乎有很好的临床研究表明它可以减少体内的炎症。
Oh, nice. And I'll say also, again, no financial relationship to any NAD, NR, etc. Likewise. I take sublingual NMN in the morning to increase energy. And I do take NMN. Oh, got it. You could either take NR or NMN. Here's the interesting thing about increasing NAD. I notice, this just anecdotally, but so do other family members, et cetera. When I take NMN or NR, my hair grows very, very fast, my nails grow very thick. Yeah, me too. It definitely is doing something for growth of those cells.
哦，不错。我也要说，同样，我与任何NAD、NR等公司没有任何财务关系。我也是。我早上服用舌下含服的NMN来增加能量。我也服用NMN。哦，明白了。你可以服用NR或NMN。关于增加NAD，有趣的事情是，我注意到，这只是轶事，但我的其他家庭成员也一样。当我服用NMN或NR时，我的头发长得非常非常快，指甲长得很厚。是的，我也是。它肯定对这些细胞的生长有作用。
Yeah. For me. For me too, yeah. There's been no clinical trials on this. I would just continue with what you're doing if you feel good and you have a good doctor that you're working with. Yeah. And how do you feel?
是的。对我来说也是。目前还没有关于此的临床试验。如果你感觉良好，并且有合作的医生，我建议你继续这样做。是的。你感觉怎么样？
Do you wake up feeling pretty good? Finally, thank you for asking. I feel great. I feel terrific. No, I feel, I could, we need to do like a side comp, you know, Zoom or whatever. Well, Sean, can we get into it. It will cost you. Can we get into it a little bit?
你醒来时感觉很好吗？终于，谢谢你的提问。我感觉很棒。我感觉极好。不，我感觉，我们可以，我们需要做一个侧面比较，你知道，Zoom什么的。好吧，肖恩，我们可以深入探讨一下吗？这会花钱的。我们可以深入一点吗？
Because we touched on it. And you do feel good. And you generally, there's very good observation. Sean does tend to have a lot of energy in a release room. But, and I give you a lot of shit about it because I do love you. And it's funny, but it's also, I do worry about your sleep. I know. And Sean has.
因为我们触及到了这一点。而且你确实感觉很好。而且你通常，这是一个很好的观察。肖恩在清醒时确实往往精力充沛。但是，我经常拿这个开你玩笑，因为我确实爱你。这很有趣，但我也确实担心你的睡眠。我知道。而且肖恩有。
My sleep and also sugar. Well, sugar. and there might be a correlation, and I'm sure there is. But, Sean, and correct me if I'm wrong, you'll go to sleep at a relatively decent hour, and you'll often wake up, and this has been for years in the middle of the night. That's right.
我的睡眠还有糖分。嗯，糖分。可能存在相关性，我相信确实有。但是，肖恩，如果我说错了请纠正我，你会在相对不错的时间上床睡觉，但你经常会醒来，这种情况已经持续多年了，在半夜。没错。
And then you're up, and you send emails, and you text, and you do stuff, you make phone calls, and you're up. And then that might be three, four in the morning. Correct. And you'll be up to like seven. Correct. And then you'll go back to sleep for like two hours. Or hour, two hours, yeah.
然后你就起来了，发邮件，发短信，做各种事，打电话，你就醒着。那可能是凌晨三四点。没错。然后你会一直醒到七点左右。没错。然后你会回去再睡两个小时。或者一小时，两个小时，是的。
Hour, two hours. And I'll sleep really hard. And you'll sleep, what you think is really hard because you're exhausted. But there's, and this isn't just sort of once a week. This is, that is the rule more than the exception. That is correct. That is how you get your rest.
一小时，两个小时。我会睡得很沉。你会睡，你认为睡得很沉，因为你精疲力竭了。但是，这不仅仅是一周一次。这是常态，而不是例外。这是正确的。这就是你休息的方式。
Yeah. Is that bad? Because I read one, like, you know, I read a long time ago, a doctor said, you know, we should all sleep like babies. Like if you're tired, lay down. If you're not, get up. I, many nights do exactly the same thing, Sean. And I would.
是的。这很糟糕吗？因为我读过，你知道，很久以前，一位医生说，我们都应该像婴儿一样睡觉。如果你累了，就躺下。如果不累，就起来。我，很多晚上也做同样的事情，肖恩。我会。
Call me back. Okay, great. Yeah. We'll work side by you. side. You know, a couple of things. I mean, some people, there's a theory that some people have this sleep architecture just naturally.
回电给我。好的，太棒了。是的，我们会一起努力。你知道，有几件事。我的意思是，有些人，有一种理论认为有些人天生就有这种睡眠结构。
That theory has been kicked around back and forth. Here's the thing. Because I sleep worse if I fight it. Don't fight it. One of the worst things you can do, this is very important for everybody listening. One of the worst things you can do is stay in bed trying to sleep for more than half an hour. Yeah. Your brain is a prediction and sort of.
那个理论已经被反复讨论过了。关键是。因为如果我强迫自己，我会睡得更差。不要强迫。你能做的最糟糕的事情之一，这对所有听众都很重要。你能做的最糟糕的事情之一，就是躺在床上试图睡觉超过半小时。是的。你的大脑是一个预测和某种。
a paired association machine, which is nerd speak for you will start to associate your bed with a battle with sleep. You do not want that. Get up and get out of bed. If it takes you more than 30 minutes to try and get back to sleep, get up and get out of bed, go do something. It is a good idea, however, to have a more or less normal to bedtime that's right for you. Like safe hygiene, yeah. Well, and we know that some people do great going to bed late and some people go to bed earlier. Oftentimes people who wake up at three or four in the morning or two or three or four in the morning can't get back to sleep but are still tired and the need to go back to sleep. I'm raising my hand here as one of these people. Sometimes getting to bed a little bit earlier than you happen to be
配对联想机器，这是书呆子式的说法，意思是你会开始把床和与睡眠的斗争联系起来。你绝对不想要那样。起来，离开床。如果尝试重新入睡需要超过30分钟，起来，离开床，去做点别的事。不过，拥有一个适合你的、相对正常的就寝时间是个好主意。就像安全的卫生习惯，是的。嗯，我们知道有些人晚睡效果很好，有些人早睡效果很好。通常，那些在凌晨两三点或四点醒来的人无法重新入睡，但仍然感到疲倦，需要回去睡觉。我在这里举手，我也是这些人之一。有时比你实际入睡的时间早一点上床，
getting to sleep can help, meaning getting into bed around 9, 9.30 falling asleep at 10. And then it just may be that you're not getting enough of that early deep sleep that your body craves because it's very easy to push through tiredness. It's hard. We can't make ourselves sleep. But I have some great tools to help you fall back asleep if you want them. But my first question is, what time do you go to sleep?
会有帮助，意思是9点、9点半左右上床，10点入睡。然后可能只是因为你没有获得身体渴望的那种早期的深度睡眠，因为强迫自己克服疲劳很容易。这很难。我们无法强迫自己入睡。但我有一些很棒的工具可以帮助你重新入睡，如果你需要的话。但我的第一个问题是，你几点睡觉？
About 11 o'clock, between 11 and 12. I'm always almost like sleeping by 12, 15. Okay, so you're falling asleep quickly. So we could go through a lot of diagnostic aspects. And you're watching television generally up to that point. No, right. Yeah, and looking at your phone. Like last night we started watching the Godfather part too.
大约11点，11点到12点之间。我几乎总是12点15分左右睡着。好吧，所以你入睡很快。所以我们可以进行很多诊断方面的探讨。而且你通常在那之前一直在看电视。不，对。是的，还在看手机。就像昨晚我们开始看《教父2》。
to put that sub type of one because I couldn't hear. Anyway. Yeah. So, such a great movie. Okay, I'm going to give a general theme for everybody because some people are early risers and late night owls. But before you get it, because this might be a part of it, and maybe you can answer to this too,
为了把那个子类型放进去，因为我听不见。总之。是的。真是部伟大的电影。好吧，我要给每个人一个总的主题，因为有些人是早起鸟，有些人是深夜猫头鹰。但在你得到它之前，因为这可能是其中的一部分，也许你也能回答这个问题，
because I actually said it to my 17-year-old last night. Again, I had heard, read whatever, because we're all experts these days, that going to bed earlier, getting those early, those first hours before, midnight and the importance of those hours versus post midnight, et cetera. Can you factor that into it too? Yeah, and it changes across the lifespan.
因为我昨晚确实对我17岁的孩子说了。同样，我听说过，读过什么的，因为我们现在都是专家了，早点睡觉，在午夜前获得那些最初的几个小时，以及这些小时与午夜后相比的重要性等等。你能把这个因素也考虑进去吗？是的，它会随着生命周期的变化而变化。
So teens often need more sleep. For social reasons, they're going to push later sometimes, and we just have to live with that. And like, no healthy kid wants to go to bed at 9 o'clock. Right, right. You know, it's just, you know, so I think it's important to eventually, by time you hit your 30s, to figure out kind of what, when would you go to sleep if the rest of the world didn't exist?
所以青少年通常需要更多的睡眠。出于社交原因，他们有时会推迟时间，我们只能接受这一点。就像，没有健康的孩子想在9点睡觉。对，对。你知道，这只是，你知道，所以我认为最终，当你到了30多岁时，弄清楚如果世界上其他人都不存在，你会什么时候睡觉，这很重要。
when would you wake up? And what's your natural rhythm? And it may be that this is just your natural rhythm, Sean. Yeah, that's what, yeah. It could be. It is true that you can create lighting environments that are best for sleep and wakefulness. And it's very simple. I'll just make this very, very simple.
你会什么时候醒来？你的自然节奏是什么？这可能就是你的自然节奏，肖恩。是的，就是这样，是的。可能是。确实，你可以创造最适合睡眠和清醒的光照环境。这很简单。我把它说得非常、非常简单。
You want very bright mornings and you want dim dark nights. In fact, there's a beautiful study out of the UK that showed with more than 80,000 human subjects that just making your days brighter, working near a window. Obviously, I'm big on getting sunlight in your eyes first thing in the morning. But if you can't do that, bright lights inside. Getting outside as much as you can
你需要非常明亮的早晨和昏暗黑暗的夜晚。事实上，英国有一项很棒的研究，对超过8万名人类受试者进行了研究，结果显示，仅仅让你的白天更明亮，在窗边工作。显然，我非常推崇早上第一件事就是让阳光照进眼睛。但如果你做不到，室内明亮的灯光。尽可能多地去户外
during the morning, especially, before 10 a.m., whatever you can get, even if you're taking the kids to school, et cetera. And then dimming the lights in the evening. I'm not saying everyone has to go to a red light environment and look like a biohagger, dimming the lights, bringing the lights down, dimming your screens.
尤其是在早上，10点之前，无论你能得到什么，即使你只是送孩子上学等等。然后在晚上调暗灯光。我不是说每个人都必须进入红光环境，看起来像个生物黑客，调暗灯光，把灯光调低，调暗屏幕。
That in combination, that in combination, greatly offsets depression, anxiety, symptoms of OCD, mania, so much so that even if people are in dark environments during the day, if they make their nighttime environment truly dark, they benefit. And there's a whole story about cortisol behind this, but for time's sake, I won't get into it. But this is a very real thing, and a modern life has completely inverted this. Our days are too dim and our nights are too bright.
这结合起来，这结合起来，极大地抵消了抑郁、焦虑、强迫症、躁狂症的症状，以至于即使人们白天处于黑暗环境中，如果他们让夜间环境真正黑暗，他们也会受益。关于这背后有一个完整的皮质醇故事，但为了节省时间，我就不深入探讨了。但这确实是非常真实的事情，而现代生活完全颠倒了这一点。我们的白天太暗，夜晚太亮。
So just try and adjust things a little bit in each direction. I don't understand how people can sleep with. with blacked-out curtains. Like, if I wake up and it's, you know, and it's bright outside. You feel like you're trapped underground? Yeah, exactly. Or like in a drug, you know, three-day drug excursion. But so I have to sleep with, right?
所以试着在每个方向上稍微调整一下。我不明白人们怎么能睡得着。用遮光窗帘。就像，如果我醒来，外面很亮。你觉得你被困在地下了吗？是的，完全正确。或者像在毒品，你知道，三天的毒品之旅中。所以我必须睡在，对吧？
That's good. To sleep with the curtains open. So light comes in in the morning, right? It's great. I think everyone should invest because it's very inexpensive in a very, in a comfortable eye mask. You know, or these soft eye masks that Velcro in the backs, you can adjust it, you know, not one that's just like,
那很好。睡在窗帘打开的地方。这样早上光线就会进来，对吧？太棒了。我认为每个人都应该投资，因为它非常便宜，买一个舒适的眼罩。你知道，或者这种后面有魔术贴的软眼罩，你可以调节它，你知道，不是那种只是像，
And it lets your eyes, and that lets your eyes move. Yeah, let them breathe a bit. And then, you know, you may try this for me one night, Sean. Get a hold of some earplugs that are those, they're like wax. There's like a firm wax that you put on the outside of ears. You don't jam on the smartphone. You may be waking up because there's noises in your environment that you're not aware of. And just see if, no, no, he's, you're convinced.
它让你的眼睛，让你的眼睛移动。是的，让它们呼吸一下。然后，你知道，肖恩，你也许可以为我试一晚。弄一些耳塞，那种蜡质的。有一种坚硬的蜡，你把它放在耳朵外面。不要塞进耳道。你醒来可能是因为你没有意识到的环境噪音。看看是否，不，不，他，你确信。
The noises are coming from inside of house. You know, I'm thinking this is you. I'm thinking. I'm thinking. Scotty. Fuck. No, I sleep with a fan on because it's sort of block out all noise.
噪音来自房子里面。你知道，我在想这是你。我在想。我在想。斯科蒂。该死。不，我睡觉时开着风扇，因为它能阻挡所有噪音。
And I think you're doing great. Yeah, my biggest fan. And if you can afford to get back to sleep a little bit, that you said you sleep really hard late in the morning, that's REM. You're dropping back. Sean, have you thought about propofall? By the way, I get it.
我认为你做得很好。是的，我最大的粉丝。如果你能负担得起再睡一会儿，你说你早上睡得很沉，那是REM睡眠。你又掉回去了。肖恩，你考虑过丙泊酚吗？顺便说一句，我明白了。
It's a steady drip. I get it. Hey, dog. What got you into medicine? Why you have a parent that was in it? Yes, at Stanford. Did you have a fascination with health when you were a kid or both? Okay, well, I'm a researcher, not a clinician.
这是一个稳定的滴注。我明白了。嘿，伙计。是什么让你进入医学领域的？你父母有从事这个行业的吗？是的，在斯坦福。你小时候对健康有迷恋吗，还是两者都有？好吧，我是一名研究人员，不是临床医生。
So I profess a lot of things. I'm not going to, I want to be clear about that. But my dad's a theoretical physicist. So I was exposed to a lot of science. So none of it's been proven. Good, good. She asked for what it's worth. I like that.
所以我宣称了很多事情。我不想，我想明确这一点。但我父亲是理论物理学家。所以我接触了很多科学。所以这些都没有被证明。好，好。她问了，值得一提。我喜欢这个。
The internet would say, we don't know anything. I mean, it's kind of scary what's happening now with kind of like calling all fact into my question. So here's the deal. My dad is an academic. He came here from Argentina, first generation immigrant, and to study physics. And I grew up in the South Bay Area
互联网会说，我们什么都不知道。我的意思是，现在发生的事情有点可怕，比如质疑所有事实。所以情况是这样的。我父亲是学者。他从阿根廷来到这里，第一代移民，来学习物理。我在南湾地区长大
at a time before, the personal computer, et cetera. But I was surrounded by science and technology as a kid. And always loved biology. Always loved fish. I've got my fish tanks. I've always been fascinated by animal behavior, human behavior. So, and then in high school,
在个人电脑出现之前等等。但我小时候被科学和技术包围。一直热爱生物学。一直热爱鱼。我有我的鱼缸。我一直对动物行为、人类行为着迷。所以，然后在高中，
I went to a quite good public high school. I, you know, I, for reasons related to, you know, teenage rebellion and home environment, I rebelled against all of that and got really into the skateboarding punk rock scene in the Bay Area and have a lot of friends who went on to start skateboard companies. And I got, we could talk stories about that at some time. I was actually, Tony Hawk's dad took me to his house when I was a kid, so I got to sleep in Tony's room.
我上了一所相当不错的公立高中。我，你知道，我，出于与，你知道，青少年叛逆和家庭环境相关的原因，我反抗了所有这些，并真正进入了湾区的滑板朋克摇滚场景，有很多朋友后来创办了滑板公司。我们可以找时间聊聊那些故事。我实际上，托尼·霍克的父亲在我小时候带我去了他家，所以我得以睡在托尼的房间里。
No, Tony wasn't there. People always asked Tony was there. And I got exposed to a lot of action sports and music culture and really loved that. But it wasn't until college that I circled back to science and biology. I realized I need to get good at something. I wasn't very good at skateboarding. I wasn't going to be an athlete or a musician or anything like that. You look like you could be an athlete, though.
不，托尼不在那儿。人们总是问托尼在不在。我接触了很多极限运动和音乐文化，真的很喜欢。但直到大学我才重新回到科学和生物学。我意识到我需要擅长某件事。我不擅长滑板。我不会成为运动员或音乐家之类的。不过你看上去倒像个运动员。
Well, I've always worked out. I've always done skateboarding, soccer, swimming, running, lifting. I enjoy sports, but I wasn't very good. I wasn't bad, but I wasn't very good. And so I had the good sense, fortunately, and some input to go, you know, what do I really love and what could I get good at? And I love learning and I love teaching. I love learning and I love teaching.
嗯，我一直都在锻炼。我一直做滑板、足球、游泳、跑步、举重。我喜欢运动，但我不太擅长。我不差，但我也不太擅长。所以我很幸运地有理智，并得到了一些建议，去想，你知道，我真正热爱什么，我能擅长什么？我热爱学习，我热爱教学。我热爱学习，我热爱教学。
That's just kind of like who I am. I can't help myself. And so I got really into psychology and biology. At that time, they called it biosecology. There was no field of neuroscience. And I started working in a laboratory. And I got super serious about school. So did my undergraduate, my master's, my PhD, my PhD, did.
这就是我。我无法自拔。所以我真正进入了心理学和生物学。那时，他们称之为生物生态学。还没有神经科学这个领域。我开始在实验室工作。我开始非常认真地对待学校。我的本科、硕士、博士，我的博士，做了。
did a postdoc at Stanford, and eventually was hired back to Stanford as a tenured faculty member. Running a lab and doing experiments with my hands is pure joy for me. I don't do it these days because of the podcast, but I still teach at Stanford. I still have my position there. And nothing makes me happier than learning information that I think people can make use of and telling them.
在斯坦福做了博士后，最终被聘回斯坦福担任终身教职。经营实验室并亲手做实验对我来说是纯粹的快乐。这些天因为播客我没怎么做，但我仍然在斯坦福教书。我仍然在那里有我的职位。没有什么比学习我认为人们可以利用的信息并告诉他们更让我快乐的了。
And not telling them what to do, but just going, hey, you might want to check this out. Or you know, you're not sleeping well. Or, hey, maybe your sleep is just fine. And I feel like there's been very little opportunity out there in formal education to teach scientists and physicians, clinicians, how to communicate with the general world. And it's usually like they have to market their book or they're talking about their thing.
不是告诉他们该怎么做，只是说，嘿，你可能想看看这个。或者你知道，你睡得不好。或者，嘿，也许你的睡眠很好。我觉得在正规教育中，教科学家和医生、临床医生如何与普通世界交流的机会很少。通常就像他们必须推销他们的书，或者他们在谈论他们的事情。
I love actually talking about other people's science. I hardly ever talk about the science from my lab, but we've published lots of papers and have fun doing that. We could talk about that. But I just love learning and teaching. And so like I said, I'm 50 and I'm just like in bliss. The podcast lets me teach very broadly. Stanford's been super supportive.
我实际上喜欢谈论别人的科学。我几乎从不谈论我实验室的科学，但我们发表了很多论文，做这些很有趣。我们可以谈谈那个。但我只是热爱学习和教学。所以就像我说的，我50岁了，我处于极乐状态。播客让我可以非常广泛地教学。斯坦福一直非常支持。
I still teach the students there. And I guess it was faded through my dad. My mom's a writer. My dad's obviously a scientist. But I feel like the only downside of getting old for me is, er, is that I'm excited about what science and medicine are going to discover. And I just want to learn about it. It's not even so much that I can use it.
我仍然在那里教学生。我想这是我父亲注定的。我母亲是作家。我父亲显然是科学家。但我感觉变老对我来说唯一的缺点是，呃，我对科学和医学将要发现的东西感到兴奋。我只是想了解它。甚至不是因为我能用它。
I'm not thinking about eternal life or anything. It's like think about how much we've learned in the last 10 years about gene editing, immunotherapies, for cancer. I'll make a hard stance here, and I'm not doing this for any political reasons. Like, I mean, whether or not you were, like, pro or anti or skeptical about vaccines during the pandemic,
我没有考虑永生什么的。就像想想过去10年我们在基因编辑、癌症免疫疗法方面学到了多少。我在这里采取强硬立场，我这样做不是出于任何政治原因。我的意思是，无论你是否，比如，在疫情期间是支持还是反对还是怀疑疫苗，
these MRNA technologies are incredible. Yeah. For cancer, let's just leave. Let's just, you can edit this out if you need to, but let's leave COVID aside. Let's get into chem trails after this, but go ahead. No, no, but these, you know, I went on Bill Maher and talked about this, and I take a lot of heat for this,
这些mRNA技术是不可思议的。是的。对于癌症，让我们离开。让我们，如果你需要可以剪掉这个，但让我们把COVID放在一边。让我们在这之后进入化学尾迹，但继续吧。不，不，但这些，你知道，我上了比尔·马赫的节目谈论这个，我为此承受了很多压力，
because I'm sort of at the interface between the standard academic, medical community and the kind of wellness, I hate the word, but biohacker community. And they're really like at loggerheads. But the truth is, there are pearls of wisdom all over the place. But science and medicine are the bedrock of everything I described. It's, you know, the only reason we even know what glutathione is or that light and temperature impacts sleep cycles. And I mean, it's so important.
因为我处于标准学术、医学界和那种健康——我讨厌这个词，但生物黑客社区——之间。他们真的像是在争吵。但事实是，智慧的珍珠随处可见。但科学和医学是我所描述的一切的基石。它，你知道，我们甚至知道什么是谷胱甘肽，或者光和温度影响睡眠周期，这唯一的理由。我的意思是，这太重要了。
And I'm like, I'm on a mission to teach what I think is the best of science and medicine. as I can see it, so that people can make it useful to themselves and understand that one of the reasons, that we are where we are these days is because of science, and I just love it. We'll be right back.
而且我，我的使命是教授我认为最好的科学和医学，正如我所能看到的那样，以便人们可以使之对自己有用，并理解我们今天所处的位置的原因之一是因为科学，我只是热爱它。我们马上回来。
And back to the show. There's so much noise out there, and there's so many people out there now professing, like a lot of people learned about that they should sleep with their room at 68 degrees because they heard Tom Brady say that in an interview, right? So, like, everybody's getting these little bits and pieces and they're going,
回到节目。外面有太多的噪音，现在有太多的人在宣称，比如很多人了解到他们应该在68度下睡觉，因为他们在采访中听到汤姆·布雷迪这么说，对吧？所以，每个人都在得到这些零碎的信息，他们说，
I heard that you should be, I just did it myself. Everything's a trend. I heard you should get the sleep before midnight. I heard that you should get this. The vaccines, I heard this. And there are so many people out there who are speaking about in this space, whether it's wellness or medicine,
我听说你应该，我自己也做了。一切都是趋势。我听说你应该在午夜前睡觉。我听说你应该得到这个。疫苗，我听说了这个。在这个领域里有太多人在谈论，无论是健康还是医学，
or whatever they're calling themselves. And you even, I forget the term you use this, sort of the, what did you say? Sort of the cold plunge. Oh, the biohacking. The biohacking coal plunge crew. Everybody's a fucking expert. There's all these fucking people.
或者无论他们称自己为什么。你甚至，我忘了你用的那个词，某种，你说了什么？某种冷水浴。哦，生物黑客。生物黑客冷水浴团队。每个人都是该死的专家。有所有这些该死的人。
And there's a little bit of fatigue because part of me is like, God, it feels like I want to put everybody in the same baths. They're all anti-vax, fucking chem trail, fucking nobody, don't trust the government, don't trust anything. And there's just so much of that out there that it's like, what the fuck do?
而且有一点疲劳，因为我的一部分觉得，天哪，我想把每个人都放在同一个浴缸里。他们都是反疫苗、该死的化学尾迹、该死的没人，不相信政府，不相信任何东西。而且有太多这样的东西，以至于就像，到底该怎么办？
What is real anymore, dude? Yeah, exactly. So what I like to do is take a step back and think, okay, you know, why do people end up in these bins, right? Like, not how did we get here, but kind of like where are people showing up? to the table. And I think that I said a lot in favor of science and medicine. I'm now going to say as an
什么才是真实的，伙计？是的，完全正确。所以我喜欢做的是退后一步，思考，好吧，你知道，为什么人们最终会进入这些箱子，对吧？就像，不是我们是怎么到这里的，而是人们是如何出现在桌子上的。我认为我为科学和医学说了好话。我现在要作为一个
insider, what I also know, which is that the field of science and medicine has done a mediocre job of explaining why, the why behind things. They tell people what to do, but people like to understand the why. People are deeply rational at some level until they're not, right? And so I think that something I really believe in is that how people come to learn information. strongly impacts whether and how they use that information. One of the reasons I do longer-form podcasts where I explain mechanism, okay, is because I do think that if you understand that bright light, cold water, exercise in caffeine will spike your cortisol in the morning.
内部人士，我也知道，那就是科学和医学领域在解释原因——事物背后的原因——方面做得平庸。他们告诉人们该做什么，但人们喜欢理解原因。人们在某种程度上是深刻理性的，直到他们不再理性，对吧？所以我认为我真正相信的一点是，人们如何学习信息，强烈影响他们是否以及如何使用这些信息。我做长篇播客解释机制的原因之一，好吗，是因为我确实认为，如果你理解明亮的光、冷水、运动和咖啡因会在早上提高你的皮质醇。
And guess what? You want your cortisol high early in the day. And dim light, lack of caffeine, cooler temperatures will lower your cortisol in the evening and help you sleep. Once you understand that you want that seesaw, tilt it high in the morning, high cortisol, you want this. I don't care if you're male, female, pregnant, young, old, whatever, and low cortisol in the evening, lower your heart rate,
猜猜怎么着？你希望你的皮质醇在一天早些时候升高。而昏暗的光线、缺乏咖啡因、较低的温度会在晚上降低你的皮质醇，帮助你入睡。一旦你理解了你想要那个跷跷板，在早上倾斜得高，高皮质醇，你想要这个。我不在乎你是男性、女性、怀孕、年轻、年老，无论什么，晚上低皮质醇，降低你的心率，
do some long exhale breathing, et cetera. Once you understand there's a mechanism behind it, then when somebody says, cold plunge is great, and you say, yeah, but early day makes more sense than later day. Or how about, you know, bright light early in the day? Makes sense. You need your cortisol, high cortisol sets away front of energy for the day. You want it low later in the day.
做一些长呼气呼吸等等。一旦你理解了背后有一个机制，那么当有人说，冷水浴很棒，你说，是的，但早晨比晚些时候更有意义。或者怎么样，你知道，早晨明亮的光？有道理。你需要你的皮质醇，高皮质醇为一天设定了能量的前沿。你希望它在一天晚些时候变低。
Once people start to understand a little bit of mechanism about dopamine, about cortisol, about sleep, then all the stuff coming at them, they can filter it through a rational filter. Wait, does this make sense based on the bulk of what we know? Now, when it comes to things like vaccines and prescription medication, let's take a slightly less barbed wire version of this, but that's very timely, which is all this stuff about the GLP ones, right? People are saying, oh, you know, so many people are on GLP ones. What is that? It's very interesting.
一旦人们开始理解一点关于多巴胺、皮质醇、睡眠的机制，那么所有向他们涌来的东西，他们就可以通过一个理性的过滤器来过滤。等等，基于我们所知的大部分内容，这有意义吗？现在，当涉及到疫苗和处方药之类的事情时，让我们采取一个稍微不那么带刺的版本，但这非常及时，那就是所有关于GLP-1的事情，对吧？人们说，哦，你知道，这么多人都在用GLP-1。那是什么？非常有趣。
The weight loss. weight loss. Oh, like Ozmpic or whatever. Very, very interesting peptide that we knew about from GILA monsters. You know it was discovered in GILA monsters, these reptiles that only need to eat once every year or so. A smart biologist said, how come they don't get hungry all year long? Turns out they have very high levels of GLP1 circulating, isolated the peptide.
减肥。减肥。哦，像Ozempic什么的。非常、非常有趣的肽，我们从希拉毒蜥那里知道的。你知道它是在希拉毒蜥中发现的，这些爬行动物一年只需要吃一次左右。一位聪明的生物学家说，为什么它们整年都不饿？结果发现它们体内循环着非常高水平的GLP1，分离出了这种肽。
We now, GLP1s, is perhaps the first really effective treatment for obesity and diabetes. Amazing. And it's also turning out to be very effective that we need more data, but for people who have what they now call alcohol use disorder can really reduce cravings for alcohols and sugar. So what happened was the medical community came out. I know, that's what they call alcoholism now. Wow.
我们现在，GLP1，也许是第一个真正有效的肥胖和糖尿病治疗方法。太神奇了。而且它也变得非常有效，我们需要更多数据，但对于那些患有所谓酒精使用障碍的人来说，确实可以减少对酒精和糖的渴望。所以发生的事情是医学界出来了。我知道，这就是他们现在称呼酗酒的方式。哇。
Yeah, everything's a, yeah, it's a pseudonym. Hi, my name's Will and I'm an alcohol use disorder. It's interesting. The only people who have no trouble with the word alcoholic, I have a lot of friends. I go to meetings like they are like alcoholics, right? Former alcohol. They go part of, right, but everyone. Yeah, anyway.
是的，一切都是，是的，这是一个假名。嗨，我叫威尔，我患有酒精使用障碍。很有趣。唯一对“酗酒者”这个词没有困扰的人，我有很多朋友。我去参加会议，就像他们是酗酒者，对吧？前酗酒者。他们去参加，对吧，但每个人。是的，总之。
Here's what's really, I think, so vital for us to understand is that, you know, if you look at the GLP-1s, they're very effective at lowering body weight. They are high cost because they're still not generic versions of them out there. The wellness biohacking community was very disparaging of this. Like, oh, this is just a shortcut. This is bad for you. There were some side effects. And indeed, you have to be careful with these things.
我认为这对我们理解至关重要的一点是，你知道，如果你看看GLP-1，它们在降低体重方面非常有效。它们成本很高，因为目前还没有仿制药版本。健康生物黑客社区对此非常贬低。就像，哦，这只是捷径。这对你有害。有一些副作用。而且确实，你必须小心这些东西。
I'm not taking them, but I know people that do and they can be taken safely. but the moment that the GLP ones hit the compounding pharmacy market and it was inexpensive, it was suddenly like the wellness biohacking community was like, oh, okay, this is great. This is just like a supplement, no problem. So people are just too entrenched in the camp they're in. I like to think, Will, I don't know, you tell me,
我没有服用它们，但我认识服用它们的人，它们可以安全服用。但当GLP-1进入复方药房市场且价格低廉时，突然间，健康生物黑客社区就像，哦，好吧，这太棒了。这就像补充剂，没问题。所以人们太固守在他们所在的阵营里了。我喜欢认为，威尔，我不知道，你告诉我，
I like to think that there is a league of reasonable people out there that represents the majority of people that are not so polarized. They're not talking about chemtrails and now I'm going to get hate from the chemtrail people. I don't believe in chemtrails. What is it a chem trail? I have no idea what that is part of it, though. There are people that think that the government is using chemicals from airplanes across the sky to reflect sunlight.
我喜欢认为外面有一个理智的人联盟，代表了大多数不那么两极分化的人。他们不谈论化学尾迹，现在我要从化学尾迹的人那里得到仇恨了。我不相信化学尾迹。什么是化学尾迹？我不知道那是什么，不过是其中的一部分。有些人认为政府正在使用飞机上的化学物质穿过天空来反射阳光。
Block the sun to reduce the effects of global warming, etc. Or it depends on the day. Oh, yeah, yeah. There were plans to put a mirror in space not that long ago to reflect sunlight in the other direction. And they try to conflate it with cloud seating, which has been done since the 50s. That's crazy. Kim Jones. Mirrors in space is something I've been a proponent of for a long time.
阻挡太阳以减少全球变暖的影响等等。或者取决于那天。哦，是的，是的。不久前有计划在太空中放置一面镜子来向另一个方向反射阳光。他们试图把它与云层播种混为一谈，这从50年代就开始做了。太疯狂了。金·琼斯。太空镜是我长期以来一直支持的东西。
That's true, by the way it is true. That's the way you look and look back into time, effectively. He went, we had Neil deGrasse Tyson and Jason had a very robust conversation with Neil. About time travel. About time travel using mirrors. It has to do with the speed of light and stuff like that, Doc. You wouldn't understand. No, but my father would.
那是真的，顺便说一句，这是真的。那是你观察并回顾时间的方式，有效地。他去了，我们有尼尔·德格拉塞·泰森，杰森和尼尔进行了一次非常热烈的对话。关于时间旅行。关于使用镜子进行时间旅行。这与光速之类的东西有关，博士。你不会明白的。不，但我父亲会。
In theory. So the important thing, here's what I'm hoping. We're 2026. Here's what I'm hoping. What are you most excited about 2020? Because there are so many useful tools that don't involve taking anything, supplement or drug, that are very useful. There are also very useful prescription drugs out there that have helped save lives. And I think people are coming to that clarity now.
理论上是这样。所以重要的事情是，这是我所希望的。现在是2026年，这是我所希望的。你对2020年最期待的是什么？因为有很多非常有用的工具，它们不需要服用任何东西，无论是补充剂还是药物，都非常有用。市面上也有非常有用的处方药，它们帮助挽救了生命。我认为人们现在开始有了这种清晰的认识。
And there are also some over-the-counter supplement things that can help that are not as extreme as either. But I think that we are finally seeing a blending between the silos of these extremes of conspiracy theory versus unless there's a double-blind placebo-controlled study, there's no way I'm going to do it type people. Yeah, yeah. And I think Los Angeles, to be fair, I've lived at West of Interstate 5 my entire life, northern South California, the middle of the state. Los Angeles is the place where this stuff got blended together. Yeah. And because people here are experimental, okay?
还有一些非处方补充剂可以提供帮助，它们不像前两者那么极端。但我认为我们终于看到了这些极端领域之间的融合，即阴谋论与“除非有双盲安慰剂对照研究，否则我绝不会尝试”这类人之间的隔阂。是的，是的。而且我认为洛杉矶，公平地说，我一生都住在5号州际公路以西，北南加州，也就是该州的中间地带。洛杉矶正是这些东西融合在一起的地方。是的。因为这里的人们喜欢实验，对吧？
They're experimental. They like to try things and see what we're. works and things get marketed and get put out there. There are no bad suggestions, you know, especially after midnight. Right, right, right. Back to Jason's original question. So your dad was, I'm kidding. I know.
他们喜欢实验。他们喜欢尝试各种事物，看看什么有效，然后这些东西就会被推向市场。没有坏的建议，你知道的，尤其是在午夜之后。对，对，对。回到杰森最初的问题。所以你爸爸是，我开玩笑的。我知道。
I do want to do, I was thinking, you mean. We talk about my dad. He's still active as an 82-year-old scientist, and he's physically well. I love that. Yeah, I love that. He's still super strong. He doesn't look like that dude who's trying to biohack his age, right? Oh, not at all.
我确实想做，我当时在想，你是说。我们谈谈我爸爸。他作为一名82岁的科学家仍然很活跃，身体也很健康。我喜欢这一点。是的，我喜欢这一点。他依然非常强壮。他看起来不像那种试图通过生物黑客手段来逆转年龄的人，对吧？哦，完全不像。
No, no, no. He's quite virile and robust. Okay. Would you agree that our generation, like us for ding-dongs, have a good shot of living to be 100, that this generation... Easy. Easy. Oh, really?
不，不，不。他相当有活力且健壮。好的。你是否同意我们这一代人，像我们这些笨蛋，有很大机会活到100岁，这一代人……很容易。很容易。哦，真的吗？
100, yes. So I think 120 is probably the genetic limit, natural genetic limit on age. I think... At this point. At this point. Look, I posted something yesterday that I just found online of a confirmed 90-year-old guy, not on any hormone augmentation. Oh, I just saw that.
100岁，是的。所以我认为120岁可能是基因的极限，自然的基因年龄极限。我认为……在这一点上。在这一点上。看，我昨天在网上看到了一些东西，是一个确诊的90岁老人，没有使用任何激素增强剂。哦，我刚看到那个。
20 full... 20 push-ups. And real push-ups. And the best part is in front of his kids and grandkids. He's got his family there, takes his glasses off, gets down on the floor. And he does 10 full, like chest to the floor, full-range push-ups, stops midway, teases his son about doing partial reps, and then goes back and does the remaining 10 and then stands up.
20个完整的……20个俯卧撑。而且是真正的俯卧撑。最棒的部分是在他的孩子和孙子们面前。他让家人在那里，摘下眼镜，趴在地板上。他做了10个完整的，比如胸部贴地、全幅度的俯卧撑，中途停下来，取笑他儿子做的是半程动作，然后回去做剩下的10个，接着站了起来。
And basically, guys, guys, 90 years old, it's so clear that because, to answer your question, Jason, by drinking a little bit less, focusing on sleep a little bit more, working on limiting our stress a bit or a lot more, doing things that really bring us meaning. This is huge. We know this from all the Blue Zone stuff, but from everything else. Social connection,
基本上，伙计们，伙计们，90岁了，很明显，因为，回答你的问题，杰森，通过少喝一点酒，多关注睡眠，努力限制我们的压力，哪怕多一点点，做一些真正能给我们带来意义的事情。这非常重要。我们从所有的“蓝色地带”研究以及其他一切中都知道这一点。社交联系，
like really trying to put the phone away and drop in with people. And really, it's such a critical... Sean. It's wonderful. It's also biological, right? It's bi psychological, how it benefits us. Plus, you know, nutrition's gotten better. I think that it's harder.
比如真正尝试放下手机，与人深入交流。这真的很关键……肖恩。这太棒了。这也是生物学上的，对吧？它对我们的心理益处。另外，你知道，营养状况变好了。我认为这更难。
The problem is it's expensive to access good food, right? but nutrition's gotten better than it was in the 90s. We're no longer messing around with trans fats. Not everyone's smoking. If you're using nicotine, hopefully you're using it. The nerds are smoking. I know a lot of nerds, I'll tell you. I know a Nobel Prize winning neuroscientist.
问题是获取好的食物很昂贵，对吧？但营养确实比90年代好多了。我们不再接触反式脂肪了。不是每个人都在抽烟。如果你在使用尼古丁，希望你是在正确地使用它。书呆子们在抽烟。我认识很多书呆子，我告诉你。我认识一位获得诺贝尔奖的神经科学家。
Everyone in my community knows who he is. And the first time I met him about 15 years ago, he chewed no fewer than five pieces of Nicorette during our meeting. And I said, why do you do it? He said, it's protective against Parkinson's and Alzheimer's. And he said, but you don't want to smoke because he'll give you cancer. So that's an anecdote. But, you know.
我社区里的每个人都知道他是谁。大约15年前我第一次见到他时，他在我们开会期间嚼了不下五片尼古丁口香糖。我说，你为什么要这样做？他说，这可以预防帕金森症和阿尔茨海默症。他说，但你不想抽烟，因为它会让你得癌症。所以这只是一个轶事。但是，你知道的。
I want to think a photo that you and me, we're going to go out, we're going to get a cheese, we're going to go get a big Mac and smoke a SIG, and we're going to post it online just to fuck with people's brains. All right. Just to cause it. Let's just do it. Fair enough. New science out.
我想拍一张照片，你和我，我们要出去，我们要去买芝士，我们要去买个巨无霸，抽根烟，然后我们要把它发到网上，只是为了搞乱人们的大脑。好的。就为了引起轰动。我们做吧。有道理。新科学出炉了。
You know what I mean? Just to mess with everything. Wait, to be clear. I'll eat a cheeseburger. Yeah. I eat meat, cheese, fish, eggs. I mean, I eat fruits and vegetables. You know, I eat like a human.
你知道我的意思吗？只是为了把一切搞乱。等等，说清楚。我会吃芝士汉堡。是的。我吃肉、奶酪、鱼、蛋。我的意思是，我吃水果和蔬菜。你知道，我像个人类一样进食。
I eat like an adult. The thing to do is eat like an adult. Don't slurp your food, don't drink your food. Sean, what'd you have for breakfast today? Be honest, go. I haven't had anything except for all. What's coming up? What's coming up?
我像个成年人一样进食。要做的事情就是像成年人一样进食。不要发出吸溜声，不要喝你的食物。肖恩，你今天早餐吃了什么？老实说，说吧。我除了……什么都没吃。接下来是什么？接下来是什么？
I'll probably have a... Be honest? Cinnamon roll? There's a cinnamon roll in there. There's also a chocolate chip cookie and also there's... Oh, my. Yeah, but I'll probably have a yogurt. That's why you take the Metsorman.
我可能会吃个……老实说？肉桂卷？那里有个肉桂卷。还有一块巧克力曲奇，还有……哦，天哪。是的，但我可能会吃个酸奶。这就是为什么你服用二甲双胍。
What did you have yesterday morning when I called you and you were on the way? You were in the car with Sean. I did really good. I had carrots and cucumbers dipped in ranch. No, yesterday when you drove... Oh, I went to Portillo's, yeah. Yeah. I drove to Pergills in Boina Park.
昨天早上我给你打电话时你吃了什么，当时你在路上？你和肖恩在车里。我做得很好。我吃了蘸牧场酱的胡萝卜和黄瓜。不，昨天当你开车时……哦，我去了Portillo's，是的。是的。我开车去了布埃纳公园的Portillo's。
There's one in Boena Park. Oh, I was going to say in Chicago. So sugar is your thing, huh, Sean? Yeah, that's too bad. Anyway, listen, Andrew, we only have a couple minutes left, because we're taking way too long. And I just want to know, just as fast as you can, because I don't want to keep you, is my mom died of Alzheimer's,
布埃纳公园有一家。哦，我本来想说在芝加哥。所以糖是你的最爱，对吧，肖恩？是的，太糟糕了。总之，听着，安德鲁，我们只剩下几分钟了，因为我们花的时间太长了。我只想知道，尽可能快地，因为我不想耽误你，我妈妈死于阿尔茨海默症，
and I like talking about it just to learn more about, like, what causes it and how to prevent it. And I took the, is it APO1, APO4 gene or whatever? I don't have the gene. It doesn't mean I can't get it, but I'm less likely to get it because I'm not right predetermined through genes. But what, you know, I mean, anytime a report comes out that we're three to five years away from a cure
我喜欢谈论它，只是为了更多地了解它的成因以及如何预防它。我做了那个，是APO1，APO4基因还是什么的？我没有那个基因。这并不意味着我不会得，但我得病的可能性较小，因为我没有被基因预先决定。但是，你知道，我的意思是，任何时候有报道说我们离治愈还有三到五年，
or we're three to five years away from something positive about conquering this horrible, horrible disease, I don't know if you've been around it, but it's just awful to see somebody go through it. Is that the pharmaceutical companies like making sure we don't come up with the case? cure? Like, what are the realistic, you know, feelings about the future of cure for it? Yeah, well, first of all, I'm really sorry. It's devastating. I don't think people can
或者我们离征服这种可怕、可怕疾病的积极进展还有三到五年，我不知道你是否接触过它，但看到有人经历这些真的很糟糕。是不是制药公司确保我们找不到治愈方法？就像，对于治愈的未来，有什么现实的看法？是的，首先，我真的很抱歉。这太令人心碎了。我不认为人们能
understand until they see someone who's alive but deteriorating. Yeah, yeah. It's awful. It's awful. The pharmaceutical companies are absolutely working very, very hard to try and solve this problem. As are many labs, I'll just put in a plug funded by U.S. taxpayers. I have to say my lab was funded by NIH for many years. This is the thrust of discovery, not just in the United States, but all over the world. I'm working hard behind the scenes to try and make sure that funding is maintained. Those discoveries get turned over to companies,
理解，直到他们看到一个活着但正在恶化的人。是的，是的。这太糟糕了。这太糟糕了。制药公司绝对在非常、非常努力地试图解决这个问题。许多实验室也是如此，我顺便提一下，是由美国纳税人资助的。我必须说我的实验室多年来一直由NIH资助。这是发现的动力，不仅在美国，而且在全世界。我在幕后努力工作，试图确保资金得到维持。这些发现被转交给公司，
pharma companies, which test drugs on animals and then humans. So it is happening, yes. They're not trying to keep us sick. Those theories need to go. Also, think about the finance, if it was just purely financial incentive, the person that comes up with that treatment for Al's conference or a cure. Like, it's like, okay.
制药公司，它们在动物身上测试药物，然后在人类身上测试。所以这确实在发生，是的。他们并不是想让我们生病。那些理论需要被抛弃。另外，想想财务方面，如果仅仅是纯粹的经济激励，那个想出阿尔茨海默症治疗方法或治愈方法的人。就像，好吧。
What can we do? Obviously, blood sugar management seems to be one important piece. It used to be, people were starting to talk about, quote unquote, type three diabetes, not a real thing. Some people do seem to benefit from a ketogenic diet for offsetting some age-related dementia, but not everybody. But it has to be truly ketogenic, and it's hard to stay on a ketogenic diet. Okay.
我们能做什么？显然，血糖管理似乎是一个重要的部分。过去，人们开始谈论所谓的“三型糖尿病”，这不是真实存在的东西。有些人似乎确实从生酮饮食中受益，以抵消一些与年龄相关的痴呆症，但并非所有人。但它必须是真正的生酮饮食，而且很难坚持生酮饮食。好的。
Some people, rare, not everybody, but managing your bloodshed, It does seem that the effects of exercise and quality sleep and avoiding environmental toxins, and I can talk about that in a moment, are significant toward offsetting age-related dementia. People with these gene repeats are at higher risk. I'm great to hear that you don't have these repeats. But everyone should be trying to optimize, I hate the word optimize, trying to optimize it on a daily basis, I should say, in real-life context, get the best sleep they can. And it's so clear that resistance training, doing some form, for women and men,
有些人，很少见，并非所有人，但管理你的血糖，运动和高质量睡眠以及避免环境毒素的影响，我稍后可以谈谈这个，似乎对抵消与年龄相关的痴呆症有显著作用。有这些基因重复的人风险更高。很高兴听到你没有这些重复。但每个人都应该尝试优化，我讨厌“优化”这个词，应该说在日常生活中尝试优化，获得尽可能好的睡眠。很明显，阻力训练，进行某种形式的训练，对女性和男性来说，
this is like a whole new world now, right? He used to tell women that you need resistance training. They'd be like, I don't want to be too big, this kind of thing. Resistance training for strength in particular. So if you can get strong without getting bigger by training with very, you know, safe. Yeah. These are the things.
这现在是一个全新的世界，对吧？过去常告诉女性你需要阻力训练。她们会说，我不想变得太壮，诸如此类的。特别是为了力量的阻力训练。所以如果你能通过非常安全的训练变得强壮而不变大。是的。这些就是方法。
Low weights, tons of reps. Yeah. Or, okay, I would go the other direction, but in any case, to maintain strength. I don't know. It's not sufficient to just walk and garden and do yoga. I'm sorry. I know there's some yogis.
轻重量，大量的重复次数。是的。或者，好吧，我会走另一个方向，但无论如何，要保持力量。我不知道。仅仅走路、园艺和做瑜伽是不够的。抱歉。我知道有一些瑜伽练习者。
I agree. It's not sufficient. Yeah, you need weight. You need weight. And so maintaining, maintaining healthy blood sugar. Wait, which goes back to, do you lift, bro? I mean, honestly, that's just... Well, now it's do you lift girl?
我同意。这不够。是的，你需要负重。你需要负重。所以保持，保持健康的血糖。等等，这又回到了，你举铁吗，兄弟？我的意思是，老实说，那只是……好吧，现在是“你举铁吗，姑娘？”
Because I'll tell you, I have a female training partner, and she's a beast. But she's not big. She's just super strong. Women, and, you know, I have a mom in her 80s. I'm trying to tell her, like, listen, you need to lift heavy for you objects. You need to do this. People, when they stop moving... I know it sounds like the usual advice,
因为我告诉你，我有一个女性训练伙伴，她是个野兽。但她并不大块。她只是超级强壮。女性，而且，你知道，我有一位80多岁的母亲。我试着告诉她，听着，你需要为你自己举起重物。你需要这样做。人们，当他们停止运动时……我知道这听起来像是老生常谈，
but when they stop moving, sedentary. Feedback to the, well, there's feedback to the brain that may help kickstart some of that neurodegeneration. That said, there are some genetic predispositions. Nowadays we're all much better off because we all know that don't do. The environmental toxin thing is interesting.
但当他们停止运动，变得久坐不动。反馈给大脑，这可能有助于启动一些神经退行性变。话虽如此，确实存在一些遗传易感性。如今我们都好多了，因为我们都知道不要做什么。环境毒素的事情很有趣。
There was the data that living next to a golf course that put people more at risk for Parkinson's. These are correlative things. We are now discovering, okay, this goes, was in the opposite direction, Will, where people were, you know, all this like round-up stuff and, you know, cancer-causing agent. It turns out that was a real thing. Oh, yeah.
有数据显示，住在高尔夫球场旁边的人患帕金森症的风险更高。这些是相关性的东西。我们现在发现，好吧，这走向了相反的方向，威尔，人们，你知道，所有这些像农达（Roundup）之类的东西，你知道，致癌物质。事实证明那确实是一回事。哦，是的。
You know, so we have a friend who's, yeah. Limiting exposure to environmental toxins to the extent that you can is going to be good, but you don't need to be hyper-paranoid about these things. So I believe there will be a solution. I just think, like, your time is your time. Like, you know, eat right exercise. Yeah, eat right exercise. Do good things.
你知道，所以我们有一个朋友，是的。在你能做到的范围内限制接触环境毒素是好的，但你不需要对这些事情过度偏执。所以我相信会有解决方案。我只是觉得，就像，你的时间就是你的时间。就像，你知道，饮食正确，锻炼。是的，饮食正确，锻炼。做好的事情。
Oh, we could have saved an hour. And stay and stay socially engaged. You know, my big push for 2026, I know we're out of time, and forgive me, I like to fire hose this stuff. People have useful things. I know they come here to hear you guys, not the guests. No, are you kidding? This is fascinating.
哦，我们可以省下一个小时。并保持社交参与。你知道，我2026年的大计划，我知道我们时间到了，请原谅我，我喜欢像消防水管一样喷涌这些东西。人们有有用的东西。我知道他们来这里是为了听你们，而不是嘉宾。不，你在开玩笑吗？这太迷人了。
Well, is we, like any technology humans build, it takes about 10, 15 years before we go, oh my goodness, we really screwed up. And we're now realizing that with, here's the thing, people will live. listen to things for a long time, but they like to view things now in rapid succession. And when you put your phone away, it's going to feel a little boring for a bit. Good.
嗯，就像人类建造的任何技术一样，大约需要10到15年，我们才会说，哦天哪，我们真的搞砸了。我们现在意识到这一点，这里是重点，人们会长时间听东西，但他们现在喜欢快速连续地观看事物。当你放下手机时，会感觉有点无聊。很好。
Your brain, it's like a palate cleanser between life events. Putting your phone away, it'll feel like you'll feel restless, you'll feel bored. Engaging with people socially or even with your thoughts, getting back to that a bit. I have a lockbox for my phone that it's locked in there for portions of the day. And it's rough, right? You're like online, all these movies, all this stimulation is very exciting. Listening to podcast is great. Audio, long-form stuff is great.
你的大脑，就像生活事件之间的味蕾清洁剂。放下手机，你会感到不安，你会感到无聊。与人进行社交互动，或者甚至与你的思想互动，稍微回归一下。我有一个手机锁箱，每天有部分时间它被锁在里面。这很难，对吧？你在网上，所有的电影，所有的刺激都非常令人兴奋。听播客很棒。音频，长篇内容很棒。
This is my push, people. Put your phone away for a short while and drop in with people. And yes, it's going to feel boring for a bit. But then that's where from the health-promoting and kind of life-enriching stuff, that's where the good stuff is. I completely agree. And again, I see it, you know, because we, you know, Jason and I both have teenagers. We see with the kids on the phones, et cetera.
这是我的推动，伙计们。放下手机一会儿，与人深入交流。是的，这会感觉有点无聊。但从促进健康和丰富生活的角度来看，好东西就在那里。我完全同意。再说一次，我看到了，你知道，因为我们，你知道，杰森和我都有十几岁的孩子。我们看到孩子们玩手机等等。
And I see it with my own kids. I've mentioned this many time my big regret was giving my kids phones too early. But then I see it in myself. And if you guys, if you can, and this, again, this is just an observation. I started noticing in public places where I just sort of try to clock people on their phone, not just randomly, but especially people going in, like let's say going into an elevator or going to a restaurant, they order a coffee. I was in New York last week.
我在我自己的孩子身上也看到了。我多次提到过，我最大的遗憾是过早给孩子们手机。但我在自己身上也看到了。如果你们，如果可以的话，这再次只是一个观察。我开始注意到在公共场所，我只是试着记录人们玩手机的情况，不是随机的，而是特别是在人们进入，比如进入电梯或去餐厅时，他们点咖啡。我上周在纽约。
And I watched people when they had, they make an order, and then they have a minute where they got to wait. and everybody, just out of habit, pulled out of their phone. And sometimes they do it out of insecurity because they don't want to look like they got nothing to do. Right. So they want to look like they're doing something. Otherwise, they feel exposed
我看着人们点完餐后，有一分钟的等待时间。每个人，出于习惯，都掏出了手机。有时他们这样做是因为不安全感，因为他们不想看起来无所事事。对。所以他们想看起来像是在做点什么。否则，他们会感到暴露，
and they feel too vulnerable in that moment to just stand there and be present. Check it out. It's really fascinating. If you start watching people in stores, in restaurants, or whatever way... I'll do it on an elevator, will. Of course.
在那一刻感到太脆弱，无法只是站在那里保持当下。看看吧。这真的很迷人。如果你开始观察商店、餐厅里的人，或者任何方式……我会在电梯里做，威尔。当然。
If I have an elevator and I'm with somebody and I'm just, I'll pull up my phone because I'm... What am I going to say? By the way, and the other... guy does it too. It's super entertaining. People don't know how to engage with. You know, it's fun.
如果我在电梯里，我和某人在一起，我只是，我会拿出手机，因为我……我要说什么？顺便说一句，另一个人也这样做。这超级有趣。人们不知道如何互动。你知道，这很有趣。
It's to not pull it out on an elevator and just stare at someone. Yeah. The whole time. When everybody's looking out towards the door, you just stand looking inwards. And then wait until they look at you and then just raise your eye about it's like, what? I'm not on my phone. It's weird, isn't it? And also bring back the art of winking.
不在电梯里掏出手机，只是盯着某人看。是的。整个过程。当每个人都看向门外时，你只是站着看向里面。然后等到他们看向你，然后只是挑一下眉毛，就像，什么？我没在玩手机。这很奇怪，不是吗？还有，带回眨眼的艺术。
You know, start winking at people. Slow wink. We'll really upset someone. Real nice. Andrew, we're winking at you. Thank you. coming today. Honestly,
你知道，开始对人眨眼。慢眨眼。会真的让某人不安。真好。安德鲁，我们在对你眨眼。谢谢你今天来。老实说，
I know. This is so great. Like, I could listen to you for hours and a half. And so I just, I'm a huge fan and I love. Thank you for starting a year off just right. Well, thanks, guys.
我知道。这太棒了。我能听你讲一个半小时。所以我只是，我是你的超级粉丝，我喜欢。谢谢你让这一年有一个正确的开始。嗯，谢谢，伙计们。
I want to say, and I know I'd speak for many, many people. I'm a huge fan. Oh, please. What you guys, I know everyone's always jocking you guys, but here's the deal. From a very young age in many of your cases, but still now you really enrich the world
我想说，我知道我代表了许多许多人。我是超级粉丝。哦，拜托。你们，我知道每个人总是开你们玩笑，但事实是。在你们许多人的案例中，从很小的时候起，但即使是现在，你们真的丰富了这个世界，
with really entertaining and really like stimulating thought-provoking stuff. And I think, you know, long-form podcast, movies, TV, that stuff I actually think can enrich us in a real way. And so that's not what I'm referring to when I talk about the phone stuff, and I think we all know. So I just want to say thank you. It's an honor and pleasure to be here,
用非常有趣和非常令人兴奋、发人深省的内容。我认为，你知道，长篇播客、电影、电视，那些东西我实际上认为可以以一种真正的方式丰富我们。所以当我谈论手机问题时，我指的不是那些，我想我们都知道。所以我只是想说谢谢。能在这里是我的荣幸和快乐，
and I'm a big admirer of the work you do. Thank you, all right. Thanks, dude. Thank you, man. Thank you, buddy. Thank you, pal. Keep fighting the good fight. Thank you so much.
我是你们所做工作的忠实崇拜者。谢谢，好的。谢谢，伙计。谢谢，伙计。谢谢，朋友。继续为正义而战。非常感谢。
I love you. Yeah, you have to come back and have so many more questions. Anytime. Please. Thanks, Andrew. All right. Thank you, Andrew. See it.
我爱你。是的，你必须回来，还有很多问题。随时。拜托。谢谢，安德鲁。好的。谢谢，安德鲁。再见。
Cheers, guys. He's one of those guys that he kind of said it, that he breaks down all that information so you can digest it in a way, you know, that we can understand it. And like, how does the person know all that? Yeah, it is great. That's something that didn't, yeah, that didn't exist.
干杯，伙计们。他是那种人，他刚才说了，他把所有这些信息分解开来，这样你就能以一种我们能理解的方式消化它。而且，那个人怎么知道所有这些？是的，这太棒了。那是某种，是的，不存在的东西。
Well, I mean, what, like WebMD and stuff like that? It started to, like, you could just go there and start asking a bunch of questions. You didn't need to, like, make a doctor's appointment and stuff. And now, like, chat, GPT, we'll kind of break it down a little bit more for you. But these podcasts or even like TikTok or Instagram, you get these little bite-sized pieces of information.
嗯，我的意思是，什么，像WebMD之类的？它开始变得，你可以直接去那里开始问一堆问题。你不需要像预约医生之类的。现在，像ChatGPT，会为你分解得更多一点。但这些播客，甚至像TikTok或Instagram，你得到这些小块的信息。
But as he said, you do have to kind of like thin out what is just the entertainment crap? Right. And what's science-based stuff? Yeah. And like what's conspiracy shit? And that's what I was saying. Like there's so many people out there.
但正如他所说，你确实必须剔除什么是纯粹的娱乐垃圾？对。什么是基于科学的东西？是的。什么是阴谋论的狗屎？这就是我所说的。外面有太多人了。
At least he's a guy who's, you know, a professor at Stanford. So you have to try to like, I'm going to try to lean towards the people who have a little more sort of academic credentials. Yeah. I mean, science is still science, and the other stuff is sort of, I guess, has always been there, but it never had, as we've talked before, it never had the platform, the amplification, the microphone that it does today. And so it does seem like, well, what do you know? Like now, like, you know, you never know what's real.
至少他是一个，你知道，斯坦福大学的教授。所以你必须尝试，我要尝试倾向于那些有一点学术背景的人。是的。我的意思是，科学仍然是科学，其他东西，我想，一直都在那里，但正如我们之前谈到的，它从未有过今天这样的平台、放大和麦克风。所以看起来确实是，好吧，你知道什么？就像现在，你知道，你永远不知道什么是真的。
No, it's just that the noise just got noisier. The science is still there and still valid. He just have to self-edit this new level of volume for nonsense and put it back down to its right size. Yeah, I mean, like, and all of the stuff that he does at Stanford and, like, he's into ophthalmology, psychiatry. You couldn't even, Sean, you know what I was going to, okay, you know what I was going to say, Sean? Just because you have that, no, hang on.
不，只是噪音变得更吵了。科学仍然在那里，仍然有效。你只需要对这种新水平的胡言乱语进行自我编辑，并将其恢复到它应有的规模。是的，我的意思是，像，他在斯坦福大学所做的一切，像，他从事眼科、精神病学。你甚至不能，肖恩，你知道我要说什么，好吧，你知道我要说什么，肖恩？仅仅因为你有那个，不，等等。
I think that, Sean, this is what I wanted to get to because you've had a few and I can feel you building up because you couldn't even get through your own setup. No, that's okay. But I want to say, as I heard you, as I heard him talking to you and you were talking about your sleep, and I was thinking like the different things,
我认为，肖恩，这就是我想说的，因为你已经喝了几杯，我能感觉到你在酝酿，因为你甚至无法完成你自己的开场白。不，没关系。但我想要说的是，当我听到你，当我听到他和你谈话，你在谈论你的睡眠，我在想，像不同的东西，
the light, the sound, the thing, the bedtime. And maybe all you really need for a good night's sleep is just a good, old-fashioned, Lala. Bye. Bye. It's going to do. I was going to do neurobiose science.
光线、声音、东西、睡前时间。也许你睡个好觉真正需要的只是一个好的、老式的摇篮曲。再见。再见。这会做到的。我本来要做神经生物科学的。
Smartless is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjav, and Bennett Barbico. Smartless. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Smartless是由Michael Grant Terry、Rob Armjav和Bennett Barbico 100%有机且手工制作的。Smartless。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。